you oh you'll like it actually last
night we let the rler talk you hit it
too early last night we let the
rler even was geted up by baby
[Music]
he the gritty Grim is shaking
fornite a GM Shing
fornite welcome
everybody um it is Friday thank you
everyone we have a fun a fantastic
episode planned today we're joined by
our friend Whitney Cummings
who's everybody L that so well how what
have you read my YouTube comments okay
fair well mine too what did they say
what did they say about you I don't know
I think no I'm I don't mean to be
negative about it but no I think you
know like I don't know probably not
great I don't want you guys to get
demonetized I don't repeat any reddit's
actually gotten a little bit nicer to me
you know do you ever get a situation
where people are so mean you on the
internet the people start defending you
and it gets cool it gets cool to like
you again I think I might the pendulum
might have swung back okay is great
thank you where it's like now like cool
to like
someone right test our audience yeah I
know that was a bad
idea
contrarian today we have zero
sponsors our members thank you to our
wonderful members you guys are the best
thank you for supporting us Magic the
Gathering is coming out on Monday
yes last night I let the
counter even the Earl of squirrels was
letting the everyone is wearing it and
looking awesome can I say something am I
allowed to just say something uh yeah so
sorry I didn't know if I was like
waiting for thing you guys have the
coolest fans really you guys you know
like Ela I'll text you like now now
you're now you're working always she
always sends me pictures of audience
members who come and say hi to her and
they're wearing Teddy fresh oh they the
people that you meet in person are the
nicest when they how about this our
fans whoa we
got
crazy are we still alive is this is what
happens when I say something
sincere just everything shuts
down we might be fine one time I say
something
likable H
yeah yeah I think uh the backups worked
baby yeah all good W we're live we're
live we have redundancies on rundes I'm
glad our our that was weird though I'm
glad we pay 30% of our taxes to
California um for this electricity to be
popping so maybe it's our over laap and
fans the people that like both of us
they're the best cuz when people come to
my shows and they're in Teddy fresh and
they're H3 fans they get they also think
we're still going to host Frenemies
together oh my God so I get I mean I
people get really pissed off cuz they
thought we I like lied to them about it
that was so funny that was just because
you had like a photo shoot with
something black and pink that's exact it
was like pink and like gray and you were
like something's coming announcement
soon yeah there was literally like a
mistake like they didn't have enough of
the pink paper so they just put in some
of the gray and I posted in a pink tank
top and I got in all this trouble cuz
they thought that I was like like blue
balling them tensions were high uhhuh
very intense it was an intense time did
then you guys want to show off your MTG
stuff real fast
sure's in that sick oh that color is
amazing um R A Dreamboat over there all
of our favorite art from their cards for
this collection we went we spent hours
online just looking through our favorite
cards oh Dam that's sick
yep that's the jacket Z the ZET the
jacket that's right okay Samantha in the
this one is amazing so good where is she
who is she
and Lena just sitting
there oh
no she got some bad Botox she got that
though oh there we go oh no
didn't thank you dream girl love that El
cam is in the jacket as well we love
love love love love love that Dam what I
like it pastle yeah so that's coming out
on Monday yes and also if you're in the
complex con
Universe we're going to have a booth
there this Saturday and Sunday um I'm
going to be paying a visit tomorrow but
it's going to be lowkey so I'm I'm I'm
not going to like announce when or what
it's it's not like a meet up no it's not
a
Meetup um but one thing I will say is
that we got a ton of MTG booster packs
that just came out they are brand new
these are exclusive hot they're still
warm from being printed uh we're giving
those away for free
boosted I don't know I think we have
about 400 so first people I guess it'll
probably go pretty fast you know there
it
is I need some Teddy fresh I'm wearing a
vest from a gas station really that's a
Vibe such Vibe I'm like God damn it you
guys all look so
cool we have some good dresses I'll I'll
send okay thank you this is this is be
this is the cutest this is '90s dream
girl you got room baby doll dress with
an actual baby baby bump in there y
obsessed yeah I well why do I look like
Theo
Von and you look like Coco Chanel this
is not fair you all look so awesome I
mean you did know you were going to be
on camera
today I hate you I did have a question
for you Ethan yeah go ahead since you're
kind of the king of lawsuits okay uh oh
I have a possible lawsuit on my hands
okay tell me about it what do you think
about me suing Aon
he so this feels right up your alley
I'll say this I've never sued anyone I'm
a pro at being sued okay got it that I I
feel that I still have some credentials
to I don't want to sue him but remember
on Tik Tok that Viral sound where I
asked Miranda costro what's your
favorite curse word yes and she goes
probably [__] and it kind of went viral
on Tik Tok so he made a song called
probably F and he took the the he took
the sound basically and made it the
chorus so it's like what do you want to
do tonight girl and she's like probably
[__] and it like has so here's what you
do okay well we sent a cease and assist
and the lawyer basically said get in
line so no you know the ceas and assist
wasn't the right you go and you you send
a demand for settlement oh that's what
you do I just was embarrassed that
Miranda Cosgrove who's this like Angel
actually wanted her them not to use that
well yeah I mean she's first of all it's
property you know it's like and here's
the other thing I found out he emailed
his lawyers emailed and said can we use
this and I just didn't see it and I just
never responded so they know they have
to ask because it's like I P that I own
it's debatable if they have to ask or
not okay but to use it it's like they're
using someone else's property like
sampling like normally you would have to
license a sample yeah so well it depends
I mean fair use has is a pretty large
umbrella and it's decided on a Case by
case basis I guess we've never dealt
with it in music very so in music there
is definitely some protection but I
don't know like if they took you guys
talking and made a song out of it and
started making a much of money off that
song they would have to pay you on it I
don't know if that's true it depends
well they did take it down they did yeah
they took it down but I didn't get like
I just feel like Miranda crove should
get paid for so well okay so if your
goal was to get him to not use it
because it just felt gross suceeded
right okay so then great yeah but then
so what do you want to sue for well no I
I just mean like shouldn't the money
that he made off It Go to her you can
ask you can certainly send it cost like
$6,000 to ask that question though with
lawyers can the fact that they took it
down is almost like a an admission of
guilt in and so I think you'd be in a
you'd be in a pretty strong position to
be like also you pay us all the earnings
yeah
plus um what do they call it um the
royalties no there's another term for
Dam like just extra damages on top okay
like paay lawyer fees or something yeah
it just felt like a little gross and I
didn't care like SNL used it and all
these other people used it didn't care
but Aon just because he's just like s do
you remember the video where he was like
humping a 14-year-old girl on stage and
he gave this whole speech about how
women like shouldn't work stuff like he
just bothers me he's I don't know who
Aon you don't know Aon he's and then
remember he's the one that wrote that
song you would love this he had did a
whole song where he's like sorry for all
the things I've done and all the things
I've yet to do like he basically wrote a
song with his lawyer to cover all his
current and
future also sung locked up locked up
that's a jam oh I do remember you
haven't seen the video of him humping
dry humping that girl on stage she ended
up well let me find it oh sorry I watch
that you have 17 people behind computers
I didn't realize you were the one that
was doing this yourself oh yeah well
it's a it's a collaboration yeah where
everybody's busy no I it's
a it doesn't take much what do they say
it takes a lot of work to make me look
this
regular Aon humping humping uh on stage
you can just find it Aon okay you Olivia
sent it thank you but if you haven't
heard his apology song oh it's such a
jam he's like can we show this is it
like super vulgar I don't
know okay he's doing like screen it I've
seen this style of Dan wild there's like
a style of dance where they do this yeah
yeah yeah they just like violently
thrust
yeah but that's the vibe is this the
vibe I guess or is this an assault
I I it's I'm not I think it's I think
it's why we have an Aderall
shortage for sure I honestly don't know
yeah I probably won't show that but but
there was a song that he did afterwards
it's really funny he's like sorry I
cheated on you I was touring with Gwen
stani like it doesn't even rhyme and
it's just him being like putting in
everything his lawyer needed him to say
publicly I will say though I don't know
if it hurts your your case if you say
that you're targeting him out of spite
that's probably not good well yeah now
that I've said this out loud there's I
have absolutely no recourse whatsoever
I'm like but all these other things he's
done I feel like I should God can use it
they're
cool different commercial yeah that's
what it was and it was also it was the
name of the song so the name of the song
was probably [__] let's get him yeah all
right I'm on it I just feel like you're
the king of this now yeah I am thank you
for acknowledging that you um let's see
we have all kinds of stuff toh share
with you today um do you know who Jay
shett is yeah the he's like an
inspirational think about him Guru he I
I've had him on my podcast before you
did what I got to go watch that one he's
a coward no we love and he's a [__]
con man oh really I despise his
beautiful blue eyes the numbers were
pretty good so
so that's what make a deal with the
devil well he's I do think that there's
a lot of people popping up like these
Tony Robins types that are inspirational
on Instagram what happened what do you
do well first of all he beat me on the
streamy for best podcast every year he
wins the best podcast and we don't got
it okay so he's OB he's so get let's get
him but he has beautiful eyes and I
don't I think I think the whole thing is
a scam like he's a total s up you think
he's like a like um factory made factory
made like a like the way that there's
industry plants hold on this D came on
your podcast three years ago that was a
while ago yeah he was a nobody then I
feel like only 90,000 views I know yeah
no I was joking [__] I'm so happy to be
here thank you innie I'm grateful to be
here I make my I make my guest dress to
match the
backrop might want to make me cut he is
very um I guess there was a a book he
wrote or the monk Mind of a monk or
something yeah I think that there's
different kinds of like s most people
can't afford therapy or don't have time
to go so I always appreciate when
there's some kind of access to some sort
of tools but isn't that what he does he
just talks about how to have inner
wisdom and yeah right in his [__]
$1,700 sweater please that's his wife by
the way what are the chances of two
people with eyes that beautiful me he's
just like if you want to have a good
life just wear color contacts and to be
perfectly
symmetrical um do you think there I have
a funny I just have a funny silly beef
with with him but he posted recently
well do you think there's a Sinister
undertone I think there's two types of
people if you don't know what it's like
Behind Blue Eyes um he posted this
recently and I know this is 100% about
me cuz this is a hilarious person to
hate like there's no funnier there's no
funnier Feud than this this is like
being like bernee brown that [__] like
I'm so into this Feud yeah that's that's
kind of the
okay he's probably the most innocuous
person it's not really a joke though um
he goes don't like me that's okay I have
enough love in me for both of us he shut
the [__] up he's always taking the high
road I love here's but here's here's
what who post their own quotes that's
here here's the but here's the thing see
you and I see different things I see him
saying comment a heart if you feel the
same so he's also a businessman like
people people that are super
entrepreneurial about their love
yourself [__] is is I'm like I'm going
to profit off of trying to convince you
to love yourself that's a con I can get
behind yeah well anyway I don't buy it
he quoted J Shetty genius okay dude wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait I
didn't see that oh yeah I didn't see
that I'm sorry bro where's the modesty
where supposed to be mod like I'm not
out here reposting [__] Ethan is a
genius wait wait wait wait is that is J
Shetty Genius of his
account probably or I does that make is
it better or worse if it's his or a fan
it does feel like people like this
there's always some Reckoning coming you
know when someone's too overtly perfect
and righteous and positive it's happen
the Reckoning is coming Jay and when it
comes I will be there tap dancing on the
grave of your
career but isn't there some is there a
backlash happening Jay no he's
oh he's literally friends with like
Oprah and [__] for no
reason all for having high self-esteem
why yeah what do you want to know yeah
dude yeah you could you know just be
happy I don't know what the [__] you
want me to say choose to be happy
whatever dumb [__] they say it's your
choice do you know being happy is a
choice Whitney uh you have to wake up
every day and decide if I don't take my
proag it is not a choice but okay well
you need to do work also I don't know if
you know this but I want you to go home
every night and think who's the person
you love most in the world um uh whoever
just G gave me a paid
partnership a what I'm nothing now who's
the person you love most in the world um
the person I love most the my unborn kid
is that the right answer okay in your
tummy sorry uh what is love uh all right
so all right Cohan my agent at
UTA so um imagine your
new that's Gary ve that's not J shett he
someone who's alive I can't do it it's
someone that's I think my baby's alive
no okay yeah but not I hope so not born
it has anybody else that you love this
is really sad hold on okay uh um you're
you're the person I love the
most not a dog well a dog dog I just
thought of a dog and I thought it um I
think it's your wife um you're my best
friend um who do I love the most in the
world well both my parents are dead just
so you guys know this is weird but I
have nieces and nephews okay so give me
the name what are their Nam names let's
say um yeah let's say that that one of
them's name is um Jessica okay imagine
every night before you go to bed and I'm
being dead serious sit there and imagine
Jessica being shot in the [__] face
with a gun with a gun okay murdered I
actually think was something else was
more upsetting wall and then think about
how grateful you are that she's actually
okay different perspectives that she's
not hurt and every night before bed you
go and you meditate on Jessica being
[__] curb
stomped that's actually ADV play the
play the Gary be I have a beef against
this is a real advice once a day
genuinely sit there for 5 minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face that's in order to like get
perspective yeah so it's oh God I'm like
different
perspectives yeah it didn't work that
didn't work what a that didn't work
there's a good there was an exercise
that book the tools called the deathbed
exercise where you you envision yourself
on your deathbed and all the things
you'll be regretting as a way to like
yeah that actually works for me
sometimes I don't need to picture yeah I
don't need to picture kids getting shot
in the face I feel wor I feel worse I'm
suing you I'm suing H3 production
yeah but the thing that pissed me off
about J [__] he always High Roads me
what what's High Roads mean he goes oh
well okay it's okay that you hate me I
love you it's like shut up [__] I sent
him a message not motivated by I know
I'm looking to see if I've texted what
our texts have been lately phone number
yeah should tell it tell you okay so
this was in 2021 you guys you have you
have Jay's phone number you text wait
wait hold
on what why I have a text with you
involved no you do not no wa shy no you
do not wait this is really weird hold on
let me download the movie look so I said
no no I swear to God I
sent I sent him a Christmas invite and
why at the top does it say Ethan Klein
when I why does it when I copy and paste
it Ethan Klein oh my God I love her but
I'm not a I'm not a I know but why did I
copy and paste so maybe we have we done
this before no I never heard from them
until like recently you're in a Maybe by
accident that I sent him so after the
rigged uh streamy he messaged me he goes
so good to finally meet you I said
congrats on the win I was being
fous he says thank you mate you deserved
it okay fine so I messaged him yesterday
I said Jay would you ever come on our
show to talk things out let's watchat
the be it would be fun left me on red
this [__] thinks he can Big Time
me since he's friends with opra so can
se's in gap commercials [__] you J shett
you know what's the saddest part of this
is that in the beginning when he wasn't
that successful I rescheduled on him
like 16 times his and now I texted him
October 11th said hey it's Whitney is
this still you he left me on
red you get he big timed you he dud he
he's right he's just like eating out
gwenth ptro eating outw you know I hear
eating out WTH peltro can actually
extend your life this is that
true she just says I wish you well you
can suck the ghost right out of her V I
don't know if I would want to get I mean
as someone that Comics like we get known
for saying all of our secrets out loud
we probably overshare the most horrible
things we've done and the bad things
we've done and all we do is air the
skeletons in our closet I don't know if
I'd want to be that perfect
publicly right you know what I mean it's
all downhill you put yourself on a
pedestal J that's what it is and let me
tell you this pedestals are easy to
knock down wobbly they're they wobbling
you brush past that wrong a little too
quick if that's a a pedestal from Ikea
you're [__] okay and so let's what the
[__] but also in there's a lot of people
oh my God he's a genius there's there's
a lot of people in
India good point I'm just saying wait no
I didn't I didn't I'm not saying Indian
privilege is at play here he's I'm just
saying there's a lot of people in India
well what I don't understand what that
means I just mean I'm sure he has big
numbers you think he's popular in India
I think he's popular here both I mean
both both all I don't think they give a
[__] about J sheding in you don't think
like if you were to go to his we don't
claim look that no um but like he's like
Piers Morgan in England um no I think
that if if you were to look check that
I'm curious can you look at his
breakdown of demographics is he not
Indian I think you might be right I just
don't know he's not Indian we there's a
scandal he might be p p oh God you know
what I mean oh here we go British Indian
he he is British Indian he's Indian yeah
British Indian oh thank God we're like
he's from Israel I'm like one parent is
like he was he was born in Britain oh
okay like he's he's British but his
ancestry is Indian I got it that's not
your
yeah he grew up in North London
according to his Wikipedia so I bet it's
refreshing to have a self-help person
and I that isn't just a rich white woman
or like a white guy telling you like
like I mean Tony Robbins being so tall
and he's just like handsome he I want
you to imagine me [__] you in the ass
he's so crazy did you see the one where
someone said they had multiple
personality disorder from being sexually
abused and he was like no you don't
that's not a real thing that's a bunch
of [__] I forgot about that I want you
to forget that you you only have one
personality or I'm going to [__] curb
stomp you in the face you literally pay
$400 for a retreat he just like pushes
you into a volcano like you have to walk
across the hot rock 20,000 like he
literally people bankrupt and ruined
their lives to go listen to him threaten
if you have $20,000 to spend on a Tony
Robbins Retreat you don't have problems
they don't have it it's people who like
we use all their oh no all on the line
cuz they think this is the big this is
what they need to what's his big thing
like when someone's like oh a great
comic this person is a great comic and
you're like name one of their jokes kind
of like what's his main thing like
what's Tony robbins's thing his main
thing um is just does he have a main
thing uh what is his main I watched the
documentary like I feel like I don't
General self-help right I feel like I
should know something yeah about his
medicine coach uh I couldn't tell think
positive I could tell you about the
secret I could tell you about Abraham
Hicks I could tell you bernee Browns
what's J said's thing think like a monk
having nice eyes having beautiful eyes
have more love in you than others but
it's interesting to me when people start
getting a contest oh I have more love it
did you put me on the Joe Rogan set is
that I was waiting for you to
see going on man good to see I don't
know we we were
tiing I'm glad you like we know what to
do man good to see you anyway enough
about J shed the guys consumed enough of
my
thought um but what but when people
start getting defensive like obviously
he like read comments or something that
he put that up who sh like don't like me
I think I'm the only person that doesn't
like me that's the thing well why do you
think he would post that talking to
audience of one person why do you think
he would post that then right because
he's stunting on me he's me he's
trolling just you I can't believe I
texted him about you for no reason
that's so bizarre that long ago and that
that's the other thing like our paths
keep Crossing he keeps on upping me I've
never seen his okay I can't I'm going to
get down and he does it without even
trying that's the thing he doesn't care
at all here here's a self-help guy that
finally actually knows me this guy is a
what is fizzy fizzy fizy fizzy fizzy
what the [__] is that mean I've never
heard of this [__] this is a self-help
person
yeah it's wild to me that people still
don't know where the lens on the camera
phone is it's uh pseudo science
associating personal characteristics and
traits with physical differences oh
someone's interesting like uh like uh
skull measuring and [__] okay well
before 19th century science listen
before you call it a pseudo science
let's at least listen to his
analysis phys this is the physion of
Ethan Klein now I've never seen him his
show but this is a good demonstration
that you really only need a minute
before you can learn a lot about someone
through their emotional type through
their physionic in watching some clips
of him the first thing I noticed was he
makes a lot of Twitchy movements with
his facial expressions he's constantly
winking or playing with his eyebrows or
changing his mouth while the iching
documents all those changes we're going
to stick with his primary emotional type
his eyebrows are expressing quiet
emotions his eyes are expressing open
emotions and his mouth is expressing sad
emotions right here's another picture
quiet open sad this is most
characteristic of him or his emotional
type this is the 42nd hexagram
augmenting honestly up until this point
I think it's just so funny I mean I have
I don't nobody told him but I have
Tourette syndrome and that's why yeah
everyone knows that but him so it's so
funny he's like I haven't seen a show
I'm like you should watch a show maybe
you'll know exactly what's going on this
doesn't make your science look good
though no you know Tourette happened
whenever loal Ary it's all about
inre serious
di that's happy sad clothes well it's
also the 402 diagram so that's your age
right so maybe there's a connection here
that's not my
age Zach it's not my age 38 um right I'm
38 [__] you guys are gaslighting me him
that he's 43 have you ever with your TR
said things that you didn't mean to say
I don't have it's more just the ticks
right there's there's different
severities people that vocalize like uh
obscenities and stuff is a quite a rare
uh version of right right Ethan does say
things he doesn't mean to say a lot but
it's not because of the I wish it was
yeah you can't blame you just said [__]
J shett like 30 times do you want to
play that back for him I don't know um
so anyway this guy's pretty great but
you know what I'll say this he's saying
nice he's actually nicer to me than
anyone else on the internet so he also
could he could also use a couple facial
ticks his face is so let lighten it up I
just mean you know what I'm saying has
it up he's doing literally nothing
pouring more energy into the matter at
hand we can see based off of his facial
expressions he has a lot of anxiety and
he's constantly I love the idea of this
man watching a video of me ticking out
and then trying to figure out I like
that he opens with like I don't watch
the show I'm very busy person like
cool this archetype is networking a lot
it's being put into a situation
uned zodia
symb volti alert and possessing
knowledge and the power to acquire
knowledge but there's also the danger of
his ideas leaving him and being
scattered so we have that strong theme
of anxiety overthinking anyway none of
those are your sign aren't you a cancer
I am a Cancer so what well no no these
Dan you don't understand I guess there's
a Virgo there's a Virgo it's like a
Virgo week you can be like cancer but
born in the Virgo week
you know what I mean like Virgo Rising
right yeah Mercury Rising I'm double
Virgo are you double Virgo MH I'm
okay I love that he's like and here's
the science of it as is backed up by
astrology like what no way he said this
someone commented on this video I'm
pretty sure he said let's go Wendy true
doesn't change anything though by the
way though t h o too busy to watch your
show too busy to for the ug is it
[Music]
you said curb stomped seven times oh I
know but it wasn't like a direct I
wasn't say like this person needs
to that was just Tim Robins and he does
do that that's literally what he says oh
whoa this little
[__] no
Tony this little [__] um Tony Jack
dhy watch out for him
go where we at
[Music]
where he didn't touch him though doing
that while he's walking with a body
guard little BR what you got to do what
you got to
do this comes off him uh his bodyguard
like last week like the biggest dude
ever punched someone in the [__] face
at a hard as I've ever seen is this guy
just go around and do Punk [__] yeah so
watch out for him I can't he's gonna get
punched in the face yeah at some point
don't you think I wouldn't say that I
hope so but I think it's I think he
should don't you think there's a little
bit of an epidemic of not getting a
little we need a little more physical
violence among punks like this I think
that's why he's walking with a bodyguard
yeah can we get more physical violence I
I just I just mean like well it's like
the um uh what's Mike Tyson said he's
like the problem these days is that you
can talk [__] and not get punched in the
face right like that's like well sure I
mean there's a difference between
talking [__] and just being a [__]
piece of little dude yeah yeah yeah I
guess how old is he I don't know like he
looks really young this last
week yeah I think we watched it before
we determine this was okay to watch yeah
like is this the guy that was mocking
the Native Americans on the capital like
he reminds me of that kid oh God
remember that one that was just it looks
like the same kiss was okay perfect I
have umbrella Insurance let's go um I
wish I got that [__] sooner um but yeah
imagine having to be The 20-year-old's
Bodyguard what a bummer so um yeah we
watched it before I'll say this the guy
who gets punched in the face he shoots
right back up he's totally fine no one
was injured
this dud was like he must be like Luffy
he's made out of rubber the way that guy
bounced
up what you talking to I'm just saying
y'all say
stop yo Ken went down hard I've never
seen anyone get punched in the face that
hard it looks like it was the neck
actually hold on or chin oh right right
the [__] face how did he get up from
that like the force actually knocked him
down like full I think that's the edit
but he gets up he stands right
up it's called
Rin
[__] so the Hooters girl's pissed so
I like that Jack dhy after this uh
encounter that he got a lot of [__] for
went straight to the mall with another
massive bodyguard and uh is putting them
in violent situation it is times like
this it's hard to say that women have it
harder because the the guy just gets
punched in the face and the girls are
like [__] you and he doesn't do
anything guard are you [__] you B there
in no danger this guy's well adjusted
he's at least three times the size of
that guy no one's helping the guy though
I think everyone kind of agrees the
guy's an assle yeah he's well adjusted
he's perfect for this position oh God
the fact that he's wearing like goggles
on his head makes it so much worse it
was Halloween I I think I think that the
um bodyguard just wanted to punch the
whitest guy
this feels just like a I've been wanting
to do this for a while type thing I've
been waiting cuz like what what did he
say that ins nothing nothing really well
I don't know they had like a he was
being kind of annoying right they had a
little back and forth they had a little
backy but what the [__] yeah I wonder if
that's I mean that that's a crime
right how I've seen this happen in the
movies isn't his face was be like
knocked in he just got up anyway he'd
have to press charges I guess maybe he
paid him off that's check storyy little
punk ass [__] out there um here's
another great one gospel
singer gets uh nominated for an ammy is
it a Grammy a Grammy and she's on this
airplane and she wants to celebrate by
Serena the the audience oh boy um her
name is Storm she was not individually
nominated her group Maverick City Music
music was nominated for best
contemporary Christian music performance
song and best gospel album the Maverick
way Hallelujah the Maverick way I need
to know what airline this is to know how
it's going to go this feels this has big
Spirit energy let's see I just found out
I'm up for two grammies my very first
time you guys yeah everyone's being
pretty nice
right congrats and I'm up for two
[Music]
gramys need to be quiet but they're
enjoying it so why we're sitting here
could I please I'm not enjoying it so
I'm
asking that's a yes or no answer please
am I going to go to jail if I don't can
you please answer my question are you
willing and able to be quiet right now
I'm doing what the Lord is telling me to
do ask me a question yes or no I'm your
flight leader he goes that's nice I'm
the Lord of not enjoying it that also I
feel like that vest under his Blazer is
optional he looks good so I wouldn't
[__] with that guy like he puts the
little vest underneath for sure she was
singing for like a super long time and
everybody was so over it like she way
outw welcomed her her uh reception it's
really hard to argue with I'm doing what
the Lord is telling me to do it's not my
places to go from there it's just well
he does he tries do he he invokes
authority over that my instruction for
you to answer my question are you able
to be quiet what do you guys
think she's working the crowd what you
guys let take a v she expected like a
riot like let her
sing [__] you dude let her
sing what do you guys think let's St if
you're not a to follow my instruction
you will not let's do a mutiny on this
damn
airplane oh okay able to beet if that's
the case then that's fine if you were
the in charge of it all I'm your flight
leader yes if you were the person in
charge of it all then time he's got a
vest yes he's in charge so did she say
she will shut up yes she so
uncomfortable once he was like yes I am
in
charge he's a FL wasn't obvious already
he's the flight leader so that shout out
to Bobby storm and and good luck on the
uh how did she get everyone's attention
she just just started talking I mean
like I just got nominated like it's yeah
pretty weird I think on an airplane you
could get people's attention pretty
quickly yeah you know I think you could
do it that guy is such a professional
though but what if they were enjoy I
mean I can't tell I can't really tell I
think if they were Jo if she's like yo
who's with me at least one person would
have been like
woo
no um yo meanwhile out in China the
people Republic is dropping the [__]
ball dude say what you will about
America okay wait wait wait so you're
ining the Chinese government not doing a
good job the whole point of like the the
communism socialism is that at least the
roads have don't have potholes in it
it's like yes we don't have any freedoms
but at least the damn roads work right
right all falling apart here take a
look waa
what how crazy is that oh my god oh oh
my God that's wild oh shouldn't this
road be closed or something that's what
you would think but the people the China
is a big place is this like Hong Kong oh
my God uh I doubt it's Hong Kong but I
mean there's so many huge cities in
China it's crazy do they have that man
just lost piece of his car didn't they
ban Tik Tok in China even though it's a
Chinese app like are we
left I didn't know if
they I think they might have a
different I don't know I don't think Tik
Tok is in China I don't cuz there's no
Twitter right I'm surprised like to see
footage like this yeah I feel like they
no but I think you can get it out with
like a VPN and [__] and this was just
like a meme account that retweets or
reposts videos so
yeah my God oh God that's what I'm
saying I'm if this is me in this car I'm
ready for democracy yeah probably I'm
ready for a republic this communism [__]
is not working just put all their money
into chis ER right babies or something
but that's what's going on in China who
would want to live
there half the world I guess they don't
have a choice yeah um let's
see oh God this original Tik Tok has 82
million
views which one this one here on Tik
Tok 2.8 million likes just this right
here thank you all right let's see you
got uh you got the special coming out
mouthy yes I have a new special and I'm
doing it on um it's only fans TV's first
special their first comedy special uh oh
I just saw your mouth do something no
I'm just like how did you get in with
like what is going on only F so only
fans has a TV network too remember we
did the roast there the bur Cher roast
and the me roast and I tried to get you
to come and you wouldn't come yeah but
that's that's not your fault it's just I
don't no I know it's your fault yeah she
came I just don't do anything she's an
adult he doesn't do anything I and the
one thing he does like we we we all
convinced him to go to the streamy
because we thought we might win the
podcast award so this if the plot
thickens I was so Vindicated you had
left your house never do anything again
he left the house he got dressed so now
like 10 years he's not going to he got
dressed you J shett made you get dressed
yeah and he will pay forever oh yeah and
you've now started an online campaign of
your f it's a hate it's a hate campaign
and we will but I feel I thought you'd
make an exception because it was a roast
and I feel like you love
roasts or did I make that up no I mean
who I like roasts um who doesn't like
roasts a lot of people I like roast I
like you know I like I like I love you
got roasted ones you got what kinds of
roast we did yeah and so it was we did
the roasted bur Cher the roasted meat
because remember they used to do my
Comedy Central and then stopped do I
mean I think commi Central just went
away it's like a you need like a plugin
to get to their Network now I don't even
know how to get to commi Central at this
point why does it look like I'm in a
mumo this outfit I don't know about it
any cuz you're in a Mumu I believe you
both look like you deserve each other
honestly you two what a couple of
[__] Jesus Christ at least I'll own
it you
got the one time every 5 years you get
dressed you wear that and he's in like
this designer ass suit this is literally
the outfit he where like are you happy
Ela are you happy I'm dressed I was
happy this it doesn't look that for the
record it doesn't look that dope though
in this photo who's on his pants yeah
this designer kid super who's like the
hot new designer and of course J shed
being a um being a total fraud sell like
oh I'll do the new hot thing no that's
envelope shop like a monk that's what it
is yeah this this suit probably cost
like 5K probably too monk Behavior okay
okay he knows he's gonna win in this
picture of course he does doesn't
he like the dominance of his hand on
your
shoulder I noticed that he was gripping
me hard it's a little patronizing the
way he's standing I was um what do you
call it floating hand or yeah I was
hovering I couldn't have the chance to
touch him cuz I felt like my hand
sizzles when I touch him I touched him
and then I felt like a Sizzle and I had
to pull
away yeah you know like a vampire
touching garlic uh-huh
is part of what's frustrating about him
is that what if he really is this
person I'm sorry I have such an annoying
laugh but look great right that is so
funny I noticed Jay shed's wife was
what's the deal with that um she
probably he probably just didn't want
you to meet
her what if he really is this person
though isn't that even worse than it
being a con what if he is what that like
what if he really is this genuine and
nice I'm not entertaining that what if
he what if he is the real deal like
that'd be so much worse I don't even
know what that means like I sleep well
at night knowing Oprah like has secrets
and is probably with Gail you know what
I mean wait you think Oprah's they have
a sexual Rel I don't know I have
umbrella
Insurance let's put that to the T well
we we don't see stemman a lot you know
do you know when someone that just like
perfect you're like jealous of or wish
you could be like you see a couple kinks
in the armor like when everyone just
realized Ellen was a dick that was made
me feel better you know what I can't get
an umbrella Insurance nobody will insure
me really sued so many
times they're like n dude that's a
horrible that's horrible yeah in fact I
can put you on my plan you can maybe
your umbrella Ella Ella a a a a okay
sorry right Bush leag move um for some
with RS I was going to say that even
after the first lawsuit which we won
they still said said nah and frankly
they were right cuz I've been sued three
times since then so they did actually
did a good analysis did you go after a
big
Corporation no ins sued yeah I mean but
but the reason they won't insure you is
because you talk so freely because I've
been sued I oh no it was just a person
well that's crazy because like if it's
like usually publicly disparaging so if
I'm going to make fun of like I make
like come after like big farm and Purdue
and like Bill Gates and like dup it
wasn't even that it was just an
individual that SC us oh yeah but if so
if you get sued they'll cover it and
then at the end they'll drop you but
shouldn't you also be able to get uh be
defended on the basis of parody and
satire yeah but you stop that's why we
won okay okay but we were still sued and
we won on that on that basis H they
should cover you if you won well I'm
going to send you my if I'm covered and
you're not that's pretty W I'll send you
my person well I'm just saying his name
is Saul how many times have you been
better call him um zero times there zero
times but I do am like I have TRS about
talking about Bill Gates and let's get
what you Gail yeah let's go after the
richest people in the world now that we
know I have umbrella I don't know but
doesn't it seem weird that we never see
stemman or does that matter who stemman
is that her husband Oprah's husband she
has a husband someone from behind the
curtain just went
exactly um yeah so just say it say a
strongly say a strong statement that's
not hedged in any way I think Oprah has
enough love for everyone
just and GA allegedly no that's you're
not doing it right Oprah and Gail
allegedly allegedly scissor LOL satire
see you're I'm working on this new bit
of no about your show I'm just worried
I'll say it Oprah and Gil they're
they're
lesbian and I'm 100% certain about it
Les's begin like that's just a matter of
fact why did they do that fine they're
bulld dyes I said it I didn't say
that um that's a joke of course that is
not a serious thank you I do think the
um there's like you know like a couple
of the like it seems like there was a
little bit of a takedown of Tony Robbins
you know yeah yeah people turned on him
a bit I don't like watching it happen to
people but I think when it's someone
who's like I'm perfect and I've figured
out life I'm kind of like okay they have
a flaw they have a secret oh dude Tony
Robbins he is a dark [__] no
there is real darkness going on back
there he has like a it's like the
opposite of a Napoleon complex when
you're so tall a gigantism complex he
does have gigantism yeah yeah I guess
that's I I but also it is a cult it's
it's a cult you also started a cult he
had like a tumor when he was a kid that
made him grow hella big and I was like
okay like a pituitary kind of D thing
like maybe that's hard to
[Music]
yes cancer
and oh we can't sorry it's okay this
button did we get it yeah we go back 20
seconds okay thank you sorry he calls it
that I never use that word say word it's
just for some reason YouTube categorized
that as like I can't imagine full
against women yeah I also love your big
red button because that's how I picture
when someone says like what if Putin
hits the nuke button like I picture that
that's what it looks like it's hit in a
similar fashion as well um by the way
this is what happens when I hit the
button it just rolls
through we done push the button
Partners but I think what was the doct o
I think or the do Phil stuff I think he
was just like toxic work environment I
don't know what that means ugly you are
disgusting I'm going to kill you he also
got a lot of um [__] because his um his
camp for troubled teens or whatever
right that was the um what was the
girl's name bad baby bad baby uh that
was like her whole Crusade against him
is she got sent to that camp and said it
was like horrible yeah i' I'd like to
hear the C camp counselor of the
story on that one it's not his Camp is
it he was just kind of like Affiliated
he would send kids yeah off to this boot
camp where they were being like molested
and [__] okay well she now makes $60
million a year on only fans so I I would
love to enroll in that camp oh Jesus
what needs to happen but I think uh it
was after he she did the catch me
outside on his show you could do only
fans I mean what's stopping you you are
on only fans on only fans but I'm on
only fans m is instead of dirty photos
and dirty videos it's dirty jokes so I
just put up their jokes why not just go
just I could live stream my birth I
don't know things could get desperate at
some point but they're doing uncensored
comedy on just their ofv TV site um
which is like actually really cool we
did the roast they didn't give us any
notes it's completely free no
commercials and it's like what's nice is
when their when their business is
selling butthole picks then
the the bar sensor bar is probably low
pretty low
isce and then um you know I was talking
to Angela White big porn star about like
what's requested it's actually weird
because like people like only fans must
be so gross but whenever I talk to like
porn stars on there that get DM requests
there's actually something kind of
charming and like endearing about it
because it's people that want to be
monogamous with the porn star in a way
or want to participate in this they want
to pay for porn which is like the
kinkiest at this point you get anything
for free but you choose to pay but she
gets requests her number one request is
men asking her to shrink them and then
she puts them in her and she puts them
in her pocket way are you serious or
eats them no [__] way what is that
what is that what is it I don't know
there's no way that's true what is it
yes she showed me the videos where
she'll go into Final Cut Pro or whatever
editing software and pick them up and be
like I'm going to eat you and she'll
just eat no she doesn't I swear to
God I saw the video we talked about on
the podcast that's great wow so I feel
like it's it's there's a lot of like
women breastfeeding women just like
cooking you know there's you can find
anything on there anything really but I
don't know if it's although we had fans
who called in one time that said they
used they used to do [__] like poop
eating and stuff and I think they they
got banned okay or they they they
stopped they said no more poop eating
okay they that's where we draw the line
which is kink shaming in my opinion did
we ever get an answer on of two two
girls one cup was real poop or fake I
think it's real really I've always
assumed that it's real for some reason
was that the first like video do we know
if that if it's fake what is we we
looked into it I just don't recall I'm
double checking right now how is that
something you forget yeah I don't know L
we talked about it which by the way I
was dying listening to you interview the
my pillow guy how he could remember
every
date you you could not drop it yeah
actually very genius the way you handled
that I like Mike we I think we had Good
Rapport and we're planning or his next
appearance it felt very like coward
Stern Energy felt very like Ethan's next
thank you so much you're like what was
the date on
that it was genius thank and he had no
idea have you seen he talked about doing
crack have you seen the video of boozy
endorsing
crack instead of fentanyl Boo's a rapper
he says smoke crack don't do fol well
technically he's proba it is probably
fol is awful cuz he says he's like crack
all my crackheads that I know they're
still alive 30 years that gives you
superpowers fyl you can like die from
one time but fentanyl's in yeah cocaine
is I've never done cocaine but now I
feel like we' missed our window you've
never done cocaine not once not even
tried it no not weird that is super have
you tried other stuff though I figured
you doing that regularly that's what
most people cuz here's the thing about
me if I did cocaine would I just be
chill cuz I got prescribed milligrams of
time release Aderall to sleep so I think
when you have a mind that's wild that
chills it out I don't think I should do
cocaine yeah I then you shouldn't I
don't think I'm not I I don't think
cocaine is a good drug I urge people to
not waste their time on it hate it well
we've tried it but just seeing how
people are around it grosses me out it
but it makes you really social I just
don't want to like start a business with
someone people always become so like
greedy and they like go in the secret
room to do it and it's like well in
college makes you paranoid I don't like
so people get really like uh my precious
about it yeah yeah like let's go in the
bathroom and do it [__] I kind of did
that with weed I had to quit
weed oh that looks good I got oh do you
want do you want to no no no no thank
you though I I quit weed in January um
thank God before I got knocked up and um
weed made me like that weed made me kind
of paranoid you know I can't smoke sweed
is I say this all the time
at least California been more [__] up
on weed than any drug me too I started
looking for the Scientology
ships really yeah I I scheduled a call
with a maritime lawyer like I was like
this is I started getting like too
paranoid but like one out of every five
or six times I did it I felt great I
felt creative I felt social like
forgiveness but then the other four
times I'm just gambling to try to get
that back and I feel like I was just
like super paranoid thing is to you
don't know how much you're taking so
like if you take too
much you're [__] cuz then you go you
do a little and you're like well I don't
want this to stop so let me smoke some
more now cuz in 20 minutes It'll wear
off and you start doing crazy math
here's the
Boba it's the milk
tea 0% sweet okay zero interesting
there's no sugar added is there are
those MA matcha ball like the balls are
matchi they're like they're gummies
right gummy gummy think it say those are
good um you want to suck I'm good excuse
me suck I'm I would I wouldn't allow it
suck it's like the most gross thing to
share with
anybody why you suck you got the S
literally you want to Sock what's your
favorite drug you've
done like what's a good one what's like
worth
it okay I'm I I hate to endorse drugs
okay because the one that we like is
super not good I don't mean like do it I
mean and we would not oh really hold on
hold on like are any of them worth it oh
there's two there's two there's two
actually the one you're thinking of I
wouldn't even mention I know I wouldn't
even the one Dr I
think we we had like a semi problem with
Tramadol when we were in Israel I've
talked about it is that the sleeping
that's what I'm thinking of yeah I know
but I wouldn't tell people to use it
that's I know is it a sleeping pill no
it's like a op it's like a synthetic
opium oh like oh nice like like a
oxycotton kind of and you just like hang
out yeah you just it's the ultimate
hangout oh nice don't but no that I
wouldn't do that but I I can't I can't
cuz like I would never when we were
taking it it becomes a problem uh got it
yeah CU then when you aren't taking it
your tolerance goes down for discomfort
a little bit too right I bet I think you
want it more I don't want to glorify it
yeah no let's not I mean so I shouldn't
talk the thing is um but it's like it's
like something we shouldn't do I'm just
I'm about to have a kid it's my only
chance to get drug this when we did tram
the thing is like when you coming off it
and I was using it like a few times a
week for a long period of time so there
was a bit of addiction going on there in
my case but you get physically so
uncomfortable like you just feel like I
can't sleep I can't get comfortable I
just feel horrible it's just it's so bad
you know yeah yeah and sometimes those
make you constipated too I oh god dude I
used to go like seven days without
[__] I've had the craziest stor is
yeah not worth it you know what's weird
though everything weird would happen to
me like your body just becomes
nonfunctioning heart palpitation all o
no good no good like also one of the sze
effects you can like have a seizure and
I was always paranoid I was about to
have a seizure I never did yeah but um
yeah don't do that it's bad news yeah
it's hor it's a horrible nasty drug um
there was one other you were going to
say the other one I would say you got to
do this again I'm not I'm don't telling
anyone to do drugs because there's
inherent risks with every drug you have
to make sure you are taking a good pure
SOA and that you're taking it
responsibly ideally with other sober
people uhuh but the one that I would say
would be is was
like I mean MDMA yeah I haven't done it
I hear it's amazing although a lot of
people would be like mgma it's the best
day of your life for like two weeks
after that you're suicidal but like it's
the best day of your life also it's the
worst cown with drugs the cown is the
worst i' rather just be pay off I'd
rather just be consistently mediocre
mentally than up and down that's why I
don't do anything yeah I can't I have
too much going on I got to go to work I
got to be there for my kids it's just
not worth it I can't disappear for 5
days no we've been sober for a long time
and it's so much better I think so too I
got like a I got like I stopped smoking
weed in January I did some of the um the
mushroom chocolate I feel like everyone
in La is doing like micro doing
mushrooms I did that a little bit and
that was like even that I was like
really not for me I like it that's
something we haven't really tried but I
know so many people it's like I was
doing when we were doing the writers
room for the for bur Cher roast all the
writers were on it you know and I would
be like so what is the they're like
we're doing instead of anti-depressants
we're micro doing mushrooms instead of
and I'm like well what's the benefit and
they're like well it just makes your
inner bully go away and it makes you
feel it makes them feel good that's such
[__] but I'm like I just got the
jokes you sent in half the words are
misspelled so maybe we need your inner
bully to come back cuz you were two
hours late it sounds like drug abuse it
kind of takes your ambition away I just
take mushrooms every day
like let's not qualify that you're
taking mushrooms every day micro doing
four times a day is a dose you're on
drugs mushrooms you're on drugs drug I
mean we it took me a long time to get
her cuz the 10 was caught on fire ever
since mushrooms have come out in La
freeways are just exploding you know so
it's like yeah I think we just have to
pick
like what was that that was me sorry I
just open the stream but um yeah I
obviously uh I would I wouldn't tell
anyone to do any drugs yeah at the same
time I know people are going to do it
anyway and so I like to just give people
like good advice on how to be have a
more likely to have a good and uh safe
experience yeah yeah but I think it's
good to go like like if you're the kind
of person who has access to him you're
like it's just not worth it like it's
just not worth it like I've I've not
done cocaine I've not done MDMA because
I just people are like it's not worth it
I'm like I trust you like I'll save it
for when I'm like in a nursing home or
something that's what I think I think
when I'm old I'm going to become just a
straight heroin
addict I'm for real dude what the
perfect time to do there was a movie
where that happened the Little Miss
Sunshine where just he was old do you
remember that movie no and he just
started becoming like a heroin addict
yeah and he was awesome he was like the
best character I I want to be him can I
ask you something that might could go
either way have you tried do br's pizza
no I think it's really good you haven't
I haven't we have tried it and there was
a lot of fans here in the I think it's
delicious and you guys like it I get a
lot of [__] for it and Liza Koshi is my
friend we can't let know about this well
do you eat that regular I well cuz The
Comedy Store is right next door so like
twice a week I was going I like waited
in
line it's the hot honey pepperoni is
delicious it's special am I allowed to I
mean it looks like the faces of the
people whose lives he's destroyed but
then there's the Vodka the the hot vodka
cheese one is also Del cuz they put it
through the oven like it's thick crust
and they put it through the oven to
crisp right before they give it say this
vodka that sounds good I was pleasantly
surprised I didn't think it was like
it's super expensive right yeah for
pizza M so I didn't think it was
like God tier but I thought it was
pretty good and some people here were
swearing by it so huh I got to give it
up you know that's what I say when I
review these products you know yeah very
impressed Hiller might drop some cucha
but if that [__] slaps I'll [__] say
it you know what I mean just that's just
how we roll I just had to out myself for
being a David Dober culinary fan that's
okay you're not the only one here's Tony
Robbins by the way he has a massive
Mansion beach house in Fiji with a
full-time staff that like kisses his
feet when so did Jeffrey Epstein like
having an island is such a red flag yep
here check it out oh hey Gabe one sec
these are full-time employees he goes
there like a week a year the entire
staff gathers the bid Tony farewell Time
to Say Goodbye again I'm so sorry but I
look forward to coming back
home he's like you guys should watch my
talk asend your
circumstances oh
God not singing him
off it's the first time they've ever met
him first of all he's just a
person he thinks he's a God look at this
[__] that hat does not fit his head he
does have a massive head though he's got
that giant head
see like that is just not normal I don't
like that he's Barefoot
either I don't like that his Barefoot
what song is
that it's it's the [__] the
white
they're I just love the idea that he
doesn't know what the song is and he's
just like and they're like we hate you
you pay us$5 an hour you don't know that
one that's a great one uh Gabe my boy $5
an hour you think they make that much I
don't know he probably just GES Sid
copies of his book probably
wayy gab what are youing you at the
studio I just want to say it's my
birthday happy birthday oh my God happy
birthday
birthday Gabe I'm so happy November 17th
what does that make you what sign is
that November 18th 18 I'm a scorpion
scorpion wow birday what are you doing
in the
stew we oh
ohing for my nephew nickn um
nicknick performance at the peppermint
Club tomorrow let's hear it Nick let's
hear it wait play some
[__] we're like rehearsing can we hear
it yeah tell Nick to play us something
play something thanks buddy passing that
on does he know can you hear me is he
gonna do
it Gabe do you are you are you in the
band Gabe or you just there hanging out
can you play the Tony Robbins staff song
oh by the way I Never Said So this has
0% sugar it's okay it just tastes like
milk peppermint Cup tomorrow for my
next 52 and 52 baby tur 52 you are the
best you look amazing ever gab you are
so youthful
looking it is amazing man and you've
been doing tremendous work losing weight
and getting in shape you look awesome
man good job thank you thank
you you look 40 he really does his skin
is amazing is that a Teddy fresh collab
no so all right you dieting and
exercising and discipline no more Fried
Chicken huh
maybe once in a
while Fried Chicken Wednesday's for
fried chicken baby
chicken what are the food what foods are
we eating during the week now that we're
on a healthy uh
Journey like yogurt in the morning fruit
and then protein like chicken grilled
chicken you're really doing it it's good
and then maybe evening maybe just have a
a bar and a drink that's it a snack bar
wow good for you man so wait are we
doing like it's yogurt Monday baby [__]
do we have anything like that yogurt
well yogurt during the week in the
morning and then me like that's what I
that's what I
say all right
[__] do you want to play
something or
no they don't seem ready play something
Pi man Zoom uh noise cancellation thing
may not be able to hear
so nicknick is performing live somewhere
is that what's happening peppermint Club
tomorrow that's a big place peppermint
Club hell yeah go catch them guys the
time when my nephew um my nephew's songs
it looks great awesome well
exciting uh I hope that you guys all
have a a great show and a happy birthday
happy happy birthday happy
birthday good night having a party
tomorrow night after the
performance
nice you're doing okay will J shett be
there is J shett
invited J who the [__] is J shett
exactly no gives a [__] nobody a [__]
about J shett and I don't hurt good oh
good that's
right well that [__] [__] that shady
[__] J Shady that
[__] that kiss my ass
[Laughter]
[__] wait whose hand is
that took a
turn by the way check GPT said the poop
was fake in two girls one
cup I don't know do we trust chat GPT oh
my
God that is
mindblowing you want to switch it up the
mic um yeah this
is are you lose I'm not allowing any
drinks get out of here happy birthday
Gabe we love you happy Birthday good
luck on the show
tomorrow appreciate the love and support
you guys are the best we'll see you in
December right you're coming to our
show yeah you better sweet and by the
way we would never ever blow you off if
you invited us to anything so I expect
you to come to our event right guys
sure appreciate the love and support you
guys are the best no no laughter for
that and we love Z too soon too soon I
love you too Gabe love you buddy all
right happy birthday happy birthday what
that's a uncle Gabe formally known as
LIF
right sweet good guy good guy all right
so people can watch it on for free on
only fans and uh comes right up it's
right there no catch no
buttholes no catch no but holes well cuz
here's the thing is they're also doing
um like specials like mini specials with
Like Comics that can't necessar because
right now if you're a standup comic you
either can get our special on Netflix
there's not a ton of us that can do that
but there like upand cominging Comics
like you know these specials where they
have like five Comics doing 10 minutes
and like they're actually putting out
more comedy content than any streamer
right now Central used to do that where
they and that was really good live at
Gotham or like you would see these new
upand cominging comedians watch the
shows all the time when it was just like
five upand comers totally and then they
turned into you know a lot of people
would get a lot of um rise from that I
think now it's like there's no way it
used to be like you could do Letterman
maybe or like Len like all that's gone
you know so there's no place to kind of
like you have your own social media but
how are you going to get any followers
or any attention if a Network's not
putting it out so only fans TV is doing
they do okay we're out here people we're
out here did the first special so I
think I think there's a some other
Comics that are going to start doing our
specials on there too but remember also
like half hours like not every special
needs to be an hour like Netflix always
says like not everyone finishes all
you'll start it but not finish it so I
think it would be good for Comics to be
able to do half hours and like different
sometimes I feel like they're too long
for no reason it's a little long and
then you'll be like you'll watch the
first 20 minutes you know so it's like
and also comedy gets stale it's like
these days like honestly with like how
funny memes are and people on Twitter
like as a comic like what's going to be
funny for a year yeah that you work on
for a year and then put out it's better
for us to shoot like a half hour every
six months instead of an hour every year
yeah cuz someone's going to get to the
premise someone's going to make a meme
about it someone's going to Tweet about
it you know so it's like just a better
way to do it I like it what I'm hearing
thank you thanks man do you guys want to
talk about um I'll give you option I
also want to ask about pregnancy okay
does anyone care I mean I do have doing
two weeks I'm doing two I'm yeah
the three week yeah I didn't I wouldn't
expect that you you don't look that
massive oh gosh thanks it's weird what
do you feel do you feel like you're just
gigantic I I'm not sure kind of forget
I'm pregnant a lot is that normal that's
good I'm trying to like not think about
it having a bad pregnancy cuz I think
once you've been like a toring comedian
it's like kind of you know like I've
flown like Southwest middle seat for 15
years like this is kind of like it's
okay I'm excited how's it going to
change me how's it going to change you I
felt like I did change after for the
better though only good stuff I hope so
you won't be going out as much be
socializing but that is true if you love
your child it's a life it's definitely a
life adjustment like we every night you
know it's all about the kids we barely
go out and do anything barely travel cuz
it's too complicated right now what do
you struggle with like screens and like
what they can watch and they can't watch
okay we don't worry about that that okay
we kind of let them watch to me it's
like anything that can help you as the
parent that's it that's what we do we
gave them a pacifier on the first day
even though they say don't good yeah
they used to put babies in
drawers they're fine they're resilient
and like our both of our boys never
became a pacifier like no I don't know
what to call it but they never cared
about it actually even though we gave it
to them from the beginning right there's
like no rules you just trust your guys
don't listen oh here's what I'll say I
we say this all the time don't listen to
those [__] the breastfeeding the
consultants and the nurses that tell you
you have to do it this way you got to
that like these people are they are
there's an article in the guardian that
came out a couple days ago that said
they're finding microplastics in breast
milk now so it's like you know like it's
I mean I just mean if you can do it
great if you can't do it fine like I'm
just you can do it great but if you
can't don't kill yourself yeah you can't
do it don't do it there's formula and
it's like just as good like on one hand
people are like you have round up in
your blood but you have to breastfeed
for two years I'm like I feel like my
blood is very toxic this probably not
great the first time I tried and it was
a whole nightmare this second time I
didn't even try don't even push it no
well the first time they were like you
have to keep trying you have to keep
trying and Theodore was like starving he
was like crying he was miserable he
couldn't eat and I'm and I'm just I get
angry when I think made the whole
experience so bad and the worst thing
for kids is stress and knowing you know
yeah your stressed yeah I was I was
given like Similac I looked this I asked
my uh family like what I it's it's like
it's like paint thinner yeah I don't
know what it is but formula yeah yeah
had formula back when I was a baby
there's no way there's been like phases
of um like I think your parents age they
did use formula totally yeah it's weird
and then it became breastfeeding and
then there was a big scare about like
your kids will be dumb if they don't
breastfeed isn't that better I don't
want a smart kid well imagine are like
two Geniuses so I can tell you that
formula has no effect on good I don't
maybe they would be smarter though h no
I'll try to do like the colostrum and
stuff but I'm not going to like go crazy
to me it's all about making the
experience as toble for you as you can
because it's really difficult so
anything that helps you do it yeah
that's it the kid the kids need happy
Parents somebody told me that earlier
that's great way to put that always
stayed with me like if you're happy the
kids going to be happy I love that yeah
I love and you need to get sleep you
need you know like breastfeeding also
another thing that I hate about it is
that it's all on the mom and then you
don't get to sleep you don't get to do
anything it's like every hour and a half
or something in the beginning they to
eat every two to three hours we're
designed to have many women helping dude
breastfeeding is straight part of the
patriarchy dude I hate dud just sleep
all night sorry babe and if you want to
help you then you still need to pump
which is also really annoying and
painful and I hated it yeah so the whole
thing to me didn't make sense I want to
be able to work I want to be able to
still be me yes dress how I want and not
wear like breast fitting tops no no no
no no we can't can't have fashion icons
in those like it the maternity fashion
is really brutal it is I'm like they
this fabric like I don't need I've never
seen this fabric on any other garment
it's like a mosquito net just to say
chat GPT relationship between
breastfeeding and child's intelligence
are top of Ono in research and debate
while some studies suggest that
breastfeeding may have a positive effect
on the child's cognit cognitive
development that evidence is not
conclusive and other factors are also
significant like nutritional benefits
cognitive development socio e IAL I mean
obviously long term long but also who
study is this who paid for it who
financed it like I'm I'm like I look at
studies now I'm like well there was a
there was like a long held belief that
if you do formula your kid will on
average be like 10 IQ points dummer I
just I
think I don't think that's based on
anything uh yeah okay yeah some and uh
but for how long you know what I mean hm
but listen not everybody oh AB wasn't AB
is a genius Steve Jobs wasn't breastfed
Steve Jobs was adopted so he would have
had how do you know that about AB he
just wrote I
wasn't why'd you write that in the chat
is the thing that's more interesting to
me is that men I wasn't is that men that
weren't are they Less fixated on boobs
as adults um I don't think it will have
any effect that's more interesting okay
that's a good question uh AB thoughts on
that
like are you an ass man as a
result go ahead have you seen my wife
I'm not have I seen your women my wife
your wife I was like I don't even know
what that means actually I think I know
what it means I think the answer is no
she's got big pendulus naturals yeah
she's a goddess okay maybe that's why
cuz you weren't you had to
overcompensate maybe it's an inverse
relationship I don't think anything will
ever get in between the love of titties
nothing maybe guys that like small boobs
were breastfed cuz they were smothered
too much as a child by
them I think we love them all yeah and
uh we'll ever change that okay I'm a
scientist I'm just trying to get some
data if parents are happy the kids are
happy you know who said that J Shetty
junor
stop
don't have you asked him to come on like
recently again [__] left me on red
text him right now what he left me on
red two months ago get the more we get
at him the better I can't should I just
write hey is this still you that's so
depressing that's pretty bad say this
hey check your DMs Ethan sent you a
message or should I just sent a selfie
or no cuz we don't want him to watch
this he knows do this every day really
is that true yeah yeah okay every day
pretty much he by the way oh I didn't
even read this I sent him like a an
invite to something and he wrote I
totally would have come to this congrats
but I'm on my world tour World Tour okay
why do you say world he know he knew I
was on my North American tour he had to
say like I'm on my world tour sorry
local bullsh about that like just say
you're on tour know you're interal the
world told you India what I say Pitbull
who are you
Pitbull and also I can't stand it with
someone is so successful doing so well
and they write hope you're
well why I don't know why it's like shut
up don't like you're I know you're not
doing as well as me but it must be hard
not to be me as part of his J shed love
rules love rules give me a break he's so
right but that's true it is love does
love rules dude that's true love rules
dude about that it
rules real real get that but is it is it
a doubl on Tandra like it's also the
rules of Love rules of love it's not
love love rules there always a lot of or
is it love rules you think like him
already which is it what Zack do you
know what I'm talking about that guy
said that one word funny I think it was
with fidia rules grow are you talking
about Grown Grow gr yeah it was gr do
you not have it maybe some people are
not motivated by growth yeah J Shetty
has 15 million followers on Instagram
now go dude
what a guy nobody watch his show though
you know whose podcast is way more
popular I never see him on the charts of
any damn thing guess who's on those
charts who this guy me but let me he had
a show like a TV show no he's just a
podc podast in the world thank you Howe
he is the number one podcast in the
world no we do oh I that's Howe Mandel
said that but he woned the steamy so
what can I
say anyway you guys want to talk about
tizzy or Boogie so here I'll tell you
this oh I think um Boogie personally I
vote for Boogie or I never did or Roman
Atwood so I'll give you options and you
guys can I wonder which one Whitney
would so I'm looking at J shett quotes
I'm really inspired um I feel great I'm
going give you three options okay I need
to run to the bathroom do you have to
pee like every second I will have to I
have to go soon so I'll pee on my way
out thank you all right oh well then if
you're leaving then why am I even doing
this because I'm so inspired these
quotes I just read all right do you want
um tizzy is a guy on Tik Tok who's like
a
mega social justice Warrior kind of guy
who calls people out and he he like what
he does is he finds people who are like
being racist or something and then he
finds out who they are and it's like
here's their name and whatever so this
guy T their address and stuff like doxes
them he shows their name and their
identity and like their face I don't
think he's gone as far as actually
doxing with the dresses it's more like
everybody
yeah but like could someone get fired
like get people they work andit I'm
pretty sure yeah yeah all right so
anyway he got in a beef and told
everyone to go harass a 10-year-old hey
what did that well let me hear his side
what did the 10-year-old do they said
he's they went in his chat and said he's
a pedophile the 10-year-old said that
the guy that does it is a pedophile
that's a tough accusation a 10-year-old
fan right away oh and so he he says
everybody go [__] with this 10-year-old
and then he took a step further he made
one he's like I'm not a pedophile I AB I
abuse children I don't molest them I
treat
kid well and then it gets even weirder
he finds this 10-year-old's
boyfriend and goes go tell him that he
deserves
better you are a pedophile if you're
like you can do better than that that
means you're ranking a child's
appearance I guess let's just watch it
if we're already here yeah no we're
we're in okay I'm canceling my thing I'm
Tik Tok
activist oh my God this guy's the man
I'm suspicious of anyone who's like a
caller outer well and like I mean he
look like this and I'm not going to I'm
not going to add any commentary about
the way he looks because it's not right
to do so okay but this is what he looks
like and I offer that without commentary
all right so anyway let me uh let me
we're going to do dizzy dizzy tizzy
tizzy I'm getting dizzy on
tizzy I thought he was banned for this
but no he's still kick he's still doing
his thing he's still living his best
life so here this is so good I mean it's
just stunning I'd like that he has a
machine good morning
everyone oh that's Vibes if you have a
moment hop over to Iona loves Shan XX
she likes to come up my videos and
comment that I'm a pedophile which I
take a slight issue with considering I'm
a father and an uncle and that [__]
disgusts me I'm like I mean yeah but
like are you comp over compensating a
little bit by did you need need to bring
the uncle into it uncles are by
definition
creepy uncle that made me feel weird
about it although why does he have J
shed's eyes why is everyone we're mad at
yeah you don't know what but also to say
that [__] disgust me you don't need to
say that um who it that said everyone's
got a molesting unle was that Chris Rock
or or was that um sounds like Chris Rock
he's got a molesting uncle I think you
that's a good joke read my journal but I
I think it's weird when someone defends
a stance that doesn't require defense
he's like I'm I don't I hate pedophilia
I think it's I think it's disgusting
like like dude why are we talking about
this I know hot take like you you don't
have to tell us you're not a pedophile I
was we got it say no more you put the
head idea in my
head uh she's one of those people who
thinks the internet exists so that her
10-year-old ass can say whatever she
wants with no repercussions 10-year-old
ass 10-year-old oh no he said that and
he also said 10-year-old ass yeah I hate
that which is a little it's a harsh
imagery for a child yeah not something
you know not something you want to be
thinking about she's a child and a
straight up child like dude when's the
last time you interacted with a
10-year-old do you know who you're
beefing with right now her 10-year-old
ass can say whatever she wants with no
repercussions uh she did make her
account private because she was afraid
of everyone coming to visit her she's 10
I was going to say she's also a child
her parents probably saw this [__] like
who is men that look like you were
probably sliding into her DM so they had
to make it private yeah and no I don't
make a comment about his looks if you
want to put that out there that's
fine you know so uh my suggestion is you
could send her a friend's request then
bomb her page once she accepts uh you
could simply report her account but um I
think it's a good lesson to learn that
you can't uh just say whatever you want
and not have repercussion question have
a great day hi also why are why is
everyone always in their car so busy
this look I'm I'm not a pedophile like
just this is an important thing to say
maybe say it in your home okay I think
he wants to look casually I think when
Tik Dockers go to work they just say so
I'm going to work honey and they get in
their car and then they work in their
car is this the original one or no this
is the followup okay when he goes after
her
boyfriend everybody so the other day I
posted a video about a young girl who
decided to jump on my videos and leave
comments about how by the way it went
from 10-year-old girl to young girl girl
I don't like any of these adjectives
true when I approached her about it she
was like I don't give a [__] I can do
what I want I can say what I want and I
was like cool and I sent you all to pay
her a visit and many of you did and
thank you for that thank you everybody
for harassing this- appreciate yall
thank you all oh my God I just want to
thank all my wonderful fans who went and
harassed this 10-year-old girl that
girl's a [__] thank you for that that
10-year-old's a [__] we're teaching
her a
lesson uh but listen this this part is
even crazier I think well her account
was called Iona loves Shawn and it's all
about how she's obsessed with her
boyfriend Shawn even though they're 12
years old well today I found don't judge
them did he just switch to better
lighting and a better
angle why is he judging them like sorry
he's like oh well they're only 12 so
that like you know you know who are you
to question they're I know he's kind of
like mocking it like they're only 12
like what do they know about love like
what you know and Shawn now here's the
thing I don't want anyone to go give
Shawn hate actually Shawn seems like a
really sweet guy why are you looking
into Shawn that much how much research
did you do for this child why is this
your hobby why is your hobby trolling
children he seems like a great guy and
he's very handsome
too uh love to be I'd love to be Shawn's
dad I think Shawn deserves better so I
figure there's got to be some followers
here that are around the age of 12 uh
lovely young ladies who are also nice so
why don't you hop over and pay Sean a
visit that is if you like good-looking
young men with chestnut brown hair who
also have Australian accents and maybe
explain wait he actually did say that
what the he just Ted
up I think he just said he wanted to
[__] him crazy I think he just said he
wanted young deserves better listen it's
not brown hair who also have he said
this about Shawn after deep Research
into a 12-year-old that he's never met
Sean a visit and doesn't even know he
exists potentially Shawn is literally
living his own life not knowing
this and this ising through his [__]
photos talking about how handsome and
Sean is 12 or 10 as far as we know yeah
yeah I love him is he the best tizzy so
I figure there's got to be some
followers here that are around the age
of 12 uh
lovely not there's zero no one there's
no one who's
12 no one is watching you dude I can't
imagine as like a 12-year-old of an
image of a person being more
repulsive like it pushes me away not
like disgusting but like it it's a
children's icon I think I would
know anyway so why don't you hop over
and pay Sean a visit that is if you like
good-looking young men with chestnut
brown hair who also have Australian
accents dude explain [__] crazy I
hate this guy oh my God I'm so mad I got
to hear that description again cuz it's
so unhinged and you said that this guy
is not banned TI Tok he's on he's still
like he's six million followers and he's
still doing this [__] where he like
doxes people yes how many followers he's
like a straight up vigilante justice
like the guy that orders
bluechew he has six you know you know
when you see someone in the wild where
you're like oh I'll pull up his page I
thought that this was like a just a
random guy no he this is why it's
interesting he's a massive that's even
crazier H yeah waa he's putting a
10-year-old on blast to 6 million people
yeah oh my God what then what did it
work can we this happened this happened
two years ago this happened in yeah but
it just like it's kind of going viral
again now for some I don't know but he's
still enjoying a tremendous success here
yeah um on Tik Tok I've seen him show up
many times like I re when you sent the
clip Ethan I I recognize him yeah I've
seen him on my timeline huh usually he
he does [__] where it's like oh yeah
he's like here's a racist person who um
called someone a a a slur here's where
they work everybody go [__] his life up
and you're like okay cool I guess F I
mean cool assuming that he knows what
he's saying the problem is with this
[__] freak is that he does so many of
these videos you know he's getting some
of them wrong at least some yeah and
that is why we don't do vigilante justi
he's like a Karen to Karen kind of he's
a Karen Karen you
know anyway this description gets me so
good brown hair who also have Australian
accents hold on chess
Brown you like good-looking young men
with chestnut brown hair who also have
Australian accents can you cut that Zach
he's definitely voting for RFK I was
also
going I don't think listen buddy uh
listen this is not an accusation but
I'll say this I've heard Jared Fogle
describe young
boy it wasn't as colorful
as you know what I'm
saying
right and maybe explain that he deserves
better than someone who's nasty on the
inside thanks by ch
he said she's nasty by the way what I
don't like is he tried to Pander to the
young people he's like bye bye bye
peace then he he does apologize and it's
just all weird and bad oh he had to
apologize for this oh I want to see this
not saying she should get what uh some
people are disagreeing well she's only
10 I uh someone said reality check Sean
loves Lona and I personally know them
and they are an amazing couple so I'm
going to find Shawn and where he lives
and then I'm find cute girls in your
area for him what no he said that he
said that by the way your area you are
area for him is he writing it like that
cuz he's talking to young people I have
to know cuz that's grooming if you're
going your area for him you know what I
mean do chat logs does he do that when
he talks to adults right his we need to
investigate other comments from him yeah
his his relationship with children
clearly
he doesn't understand what's appropriate
and that makes me very worried um it's
not appropriate to respond to them in
any capacity no not at all you're
absolutely right about that she's also
10 that's not okay for Tim Tik Tok and
still he's right but you I I mean he's
talking to kids he says means the
government won't arrest you for saying
what they don't like you can still catch
a beating uh wow does he always type
like that that's a good
question
that his victim was 12 and everyone told
him repeatedly she was 10 oh yeah well
if she's 12 it's fine okay yeah it's
that changes everything yeah heuse same
exact I mean you know 12 12y olds are
considered adults um he even stated in
his first video that she was 10 he said
both 10 and 12 he's definitely I think
what he said is she's 10 and her
boyfriend is 12 maybe okay either way he
knows that it's somewhere in that age I
remember because you said 10-year-old
ass right that's right they or no well
he also was the first to say that it was
2 years ago so is that video from two
years ago and this video from now what
no I think this is all from okay when
did he when did he apologize this all
happened two years ago okay got it yeah
I never saw it though and I see this guy
on my timeline huh I'd like to know
these things what is this [__] what
happened I had no idea any of this was
even going on yeah it's been a hell of a
week and a half how long ago was the Tik
Tok on the 10-year-old made beginning of
2019 like I still uh she was and she was
12 not that it
matters I let my own trauma be triggered
and made a bad
decision I would never make play in the
trauma card yeah what okay all right
okay not sure my trauma makes me want to
[__] find the good lighting angle but
you know okay each his own I
know here comes the boy say I'm not here
to make excuses um this video is being
made because I don't want people to
attack others I don't want people to
attack black and white cuz it's the
apology video I don't why do people do
this remember when um during the
pandemic when celebrities made a video
about staying inside and it was in black
and
white Imagine song was that in black and
white there were two no there's the
Travis Scott did a black and white
because he killed a bunch of people or
well he was respons I think youed
responsible for people dying right
I don't think that's an I think like are
they going through the filters to find
the apology filter is just black and
white now I don't know if somebody
edited it though cuz we're watching a a
reupload so I have no idea it's weird
the other ones weren't though you're
right I think he might have done black
and white just based on the fact that
the other ones weren't but we don't know
it just makes you look older it makes
you look like you were born in the 20s
right he's like look at me and my co our
extra sister and Karen or anyone for
having a problem with something that
I've done people wearing a shirt with
Devil horn on
it like different shirt
dude different
shirt like you'd be wearing a Rugrat
shirt or some
just you know like it has a literal
devil on the front of his shirt to are
mutuals of mine have been associated
with me should be able to say hey I'm
not okay with what this person said or
did and that be okay because otherwise
people will assume that they are okay
with it but see how he won't look at the
I feel like he's looking away much more
in this video the other ones he was
looking down the barrel now all of a
sudden he's like I'm so sorry who were
like what was the context of that what
were you saying so I'm going to explain
that again not as an excuse so this is
back when I was still just lipsyncing on
the app I wasn't doing any kind of
advocacy that's even worse than being a
pedophile Fu wait wait wait wait wait
wait you were lip syncing can you find
what he doing lipn has he apologize for
the lip sinking I'm going to pull one of
those up I got to oh my God no maybe
100K followers at that time 100 I had
that's not a nobody a girl who came into
my comments and was making posts calling
me a pedophile I think well okay look if
if and again I don't like to generalize
on how people look okay you really want
you want to talk about how he looks
let's do it no I wouldn't I wouldn't do
that it's inappropriate and I do it fair
if a guy like this goes on Tik Tok who
looks like this and makes lipsyncing
videos you have to hedge in a little bit
of your pedophile comments like it's
gonna it's and again I'm not saying it's
right read the room I'm not saying it's
warranted but what I am saying it is I
totally understand where they're coming
from yes agree just kidding I he looks
like the guy who pays I don't understand
where they're coming from he looks like
the guy who would pay the mall to work
as the
Santa
no I don't know what I don't I say
nothing but he's an uncle so we're good
he's an uncle and yeah people have
realized at this point that that's
triggering for reasons I won't go into
um so I first reached up I think he's
implying that implying that he is a
potentially vitim victim yeah okay and
therefore he can harass
children that's what I am I love that
people all of a sudden when they're in
the wrong start saying triggered like I
know that's triggering like someone was
like you have
to say that word well I mean I think it
in their mind it helps them rationalize
it for
themselves but it's a way of not taking
responsibility like I was I was
triggered I didn't make the choice to do
all that like I was just triggered it's
a horrible apology it's just an
excuse to her was like wow that's really
not cool you can really hurt someone by
doing that and her response was [__] you
I don't care 10
so I don't you have kids man like what
what the [__] why are you beefing with a
10y old okay but have you guys seen a
10-year-old recently like they're kids
it's one it's one away from nine
yeah literally yeah it's it's almost n
almost n one digit age yeah that says a
lot Jesus now I want it to be clear I I
didn't get any information on this
person I never sent anybody to like
their Instagram or uh somewhere if
anybody wants to have a look at a sexy
young boy with chestnut colored hair and
beautiful I love to here's what I didn't
here's what I didn't do we don't care
what you didn't do what you did do is
bad enough where she goes to school all
of this was contained on I didn't say
where she went to school he said her
username verbatim right and then he said
go and said go to her page he literally
said go harass her that's awesome but I
didn't say where her school
was right I didn't say exact I didn't
tell you her exact address like I know
it don't get me wrong right like I could
have like I feel like he's like I could
have told you where she lives where she
goes to school I didn't go as hard as I
could okay cuz I've got that in my favor
saved he's actually mad at this
10-year-old like he actually hates this
child but I made that and at the time I
really didn't understand what making a
post like that how your well at your age
how your what you told people to respond
to that
went private right because it never
dawned on you that you she could I'll go
back here wa dad how your followers
could respond to that like it never
dawned on me that she could get a ton of
hate messages I thought people literally
celebrating it he was celebrating it you
said pay her a visit
yeah didn't dawn on me that's people
would pay me a visit go politely educate
her about why her comment was
offensive would just go like hey that's
not cool it's really wrong what you
would do that and honestly that is what
people did she didn't get a bunch of
hate messages out of it but she
responded again like I don't give a [__]
all of you blah blah blah oh so it's
it's she said I don't give a [__] I
don't think she said that but right
that's what pushed him over the edge
though he says it was uh he's saying
it's her fault but I love that he's
still doing a patronizing impression of
her and then she was like I don't give a
[__] so I'm really sorry it's like you
you're still mocking child it is a
horrible apology he still hates on Tik
Tok saying maybe there's a nice girl who
would like to be with him again well
hold on again did you pull the sound
bite you want me to do it now oh well I
mean I can you don't have to I just
thought maybe I mean something about
chest beautiful chest not hair I like
when people [__] up and then they go
like and again like as if like you're
not following like and again I did it
this way like just keep up and listen
like he's being so patri izing to
everyone have you ever had to make a
public
apology I probably should have I've done
a lot but I haven't one time I made fun
I went on the James Gordon show and made
fun of my family being from West
Virginia and it got so bad really that I
went there yeah and didny yeah West
virginny I like went there and like did
a podcast and they like explained to me
why when you like when you make fun of
places like I mean like my family makes
fun of it because we're from there and
we're backwards and all the stuff but
they explained to me that it like makes
it like this stereotype where companies
don't go there and people don't visit
and yeah like hurts tourism never make
fun of those types of people well being
from
that what types what are you implying
the uh the uh
yis
yeah the hill Bo he doesn't have an
impression that he does a lot I respect
our good old southern brother there why
all right let's go not really
understanding what could have come from
that and I'm very fortunate that it
didn't result in a bunch of people just
harassing them but that doesn't change
the fact that it could have it doesn't
change the fact that it's wrong and I
was wrong and it's something well I
would never do it
today I did it then now lately there's
been a lot of focus on things that I've
done or said in the past and it causes a
lot of people to have to make content on
it or address it and that causes people
to not be able to focus on the good
things they should be focusing on I mean
des and our Exorcist were swatted and
almost no one's talking about it it's
that's not right the part so I watched
this whole thing and it's all
interesting the part where I was like my
jaw dropped was his tweets the old
tweets that came about seen that but did
he just bring up a swatting like it's
like when you have an issue with someone
and they're like yeah I mean I'm sorry
but like you know there's a war going on
so and you're like well that's not what
we're talking about he's like I mean we
shouldn't have to focus on this someone
got swatted know one will talk about
that but anyway yeah I didn't
swatter you guys mad about being here
right now seems to be a distraction and
I don't want to be a
distraction so I am going to take some
time off from this app be a celebrity to
reflect and look at what I can do to be
better they're good creators doing good
things even ones who have had a problem
with me and I want them to be able to
focus on that so please support them and
let's try and get back I'm getting like
Boogie apology energy you know what I
mean
real good that inact real oh
[__] have you have you ever tried anon's
chocolate no the bag I can tell by the
bag it's fancy it's the best chocolate
ever it what country from here it's made
from here yeah they have a store in
Beverly actually yes please great guys
good people but we met the we met one of
the sons so nice two sons we met Mark
that better be a massive one there's a
lot it really was the best you I one
time there's a place in New York that
was like Belgian chocolate hold on
there's sorry cross combo okay no I have
nothing I want to try it it's just that
it's a 24 piece jelly chocolate uh
package all right but there's there's
other stuff is it really that one feels
like a I feel like it can't be jelly in
there for real oh my God is he trolling
You Ethan was saying how he doesn't like
jelly chocolate I said why do you make
jelly it is the it is the weirdest one I
say 100% of the people that get those
are
disappointed we actually did a poll and
like 50% like 80% of people in LA are
high so high I bet it's delicious I got
to say this about the chocolate Wars we
had on the show no jelly okay giant box
says no
jelly oh my God they're so funny they
actually made a whole box of jelly ones
that's so nice so this guy he makes Aran
chocolates here in LA and it was
recommended To Us by a friend to the
show wow are [__] nuts nuts do your
uh but do your fans hate it when you eat
no no it's F okay I mean they do but
it's fine every time I eat on my podcast
you're used to it here on this show
before we get into the Anton's treasure
54 piece now this is what I'm talking
about Je thank you man his name is Mark
well but does it tell you on the top of
the box what every all what they all are
yes we have I think there's only four in
here but there's a caramel gingerbread
waffle a s'mores a Massa hot chocolate
and a sticky toffee pudding
wow I'm telling you dude there's a bunch
more over here tooing out everyone's
gathered around there hazelnut truffles
yeah so here's what I want to say this
about the chocolate Wars you can go can
you open this while I let me see so we
had ANS sons and we also had um and
everything look like a piece of it's
cool that's gorgeous oh [__] dude God
okay let's
see ridiculous that hard cuz sometimes
you eat chocolate and you're like that
wasn't worth it you know what I mean yes
oh what is that look how cute thank
you oh my God oh my God it's crazy it's
crazy
right okay oh my God if you like guys
I'm giving birth wait and it has like a
little bit of salt on it kind of oh wow
oh my God so wait hold on Anon oh wow an
Suns came on
wait this one is so good everybody was
enamored they loved and they sold out of
chocolate they have no chocolate then
this guy the owner of compart compartes
came over and tried to do a chocolate
contest now
listen happy he came it was great to
meet him but I have to be I have to say
because a lot of people have been
ordering
compartes and some people have been
saying it arrived melted and that it
okay look at this work of art have seen
this I have seen it's a work of art you
guys I have seen I can't that looks like
a painted these are crazy let me just
say let me say this an Sons is the
official chocolate of the a pug wow it's
official people I don't even want to eat
it m um um what the [__] their name is
um know
what but what I will say is that I don't
even want to eat it if you're looking
for beautiful I have seen a special
chocolate experience it's an Suns that's
what you need okay I don't know if this
I don't even want to eat it like this is
look at that okay these those ones are
my faves the oh and there's this
oh which one the blue one let me see oh
my God I got the caramel one M oh my God
I think this might be like exactly what
I dreamed of really oh that's so cute
what
painted a oh my God
thank you guys I love this so nice to
you guys and I'll tell you what Jeff oh
my God since you're watch I know you're
watching that's insane amazing right
it's also just
perfectly constructed yeah and the
textures they nail the textures like
it's just amazing I've never had
anything like that cuz you know normally
you have one and you're like that's
fight it's like a Kit Kat kind of like a
nice Kit Kat or that's like a nice
that's like on another level that's what
I'll say was compart tast it's like okay
it's chocolate but this is something
special wow I'll say this my God Jeff if
you are watching and you
are thank you so much thank you so much
just keep us if you keep us [__] up
look at can we show the the what what's
going on back here look at these
guys can we see shot everybody's
just huddled around dude nobody's
working anymore
look look
sparkly spark yeah it's my gold it's got
sparkles on it
what I'm saying is um oh what the hell
which one did you try I've never seen
the crew like this never I mean what the
hell we got a show to do this is sh I
this is worth whatever diabetes I'm
currently
getting I don't know which one to eat no
oh what is
that all kinds of stuff the best day of
my life oh my God
whoa M it's like a dick thing on that
wow sorry and they you can get this all
over the like if people can order from
anywhere from their chocolate none left
after they came on look you've ruined
their business great oh he wanted me to
tell so part of what we got is like
their holiday stuff and it's dropping on
Monday at 12:00 p.m. Pacific time so
that's worth it like when someone gives
you like a seized candy for
Christmas that's kind of interesting
you're kind of like H yeah I love these
let's sh okay that's that that's the
most insane thing that's crazy I've had
a lot of wild things in my mouth that's
the wildest um but it has some jelly in
it you might what I was going to say is
that Jeff if you keep us stocked up on
chocolate then we you can remain the
official well he actually said uh we did
it where the official a street chocolate
I'm retiring thank you he's out oh he's
messaging you right now yeah he just
messaged me I let him know that he just
getting started you're just getting
started you can't retire you just got
the O list you you cannot retire ah oh
this one's really good you try that one
or trade me here
trade you want more you have the pink
one I just had three of those I feel
what's that
flavor I don't even care I don't even
care well cuz you know sometimes they're
like good be like yum yum like right oh
wow I think that's the theor one you
want to try I mean they're all so good
here P that this is fixing my childhood
you guys holy [__] that's good look at
this spread
M anything else I think that's the one
oh green tea I love breaking the little
shell so um anyway thank you and Sons
for the thank you so much this is you
guys are on another
level my God this is like peanut butter
and jelly it's like a mini oh yes it's
sput butter and jelly oh my
God obsessed oh these this is the jelly
one who ened me
this their jellies are good I'm not on
your side about this seriously usually I
hate it but usually it's too viscous
this is like liquidy it kind of just
like oozes in your mouth I'm a I'm a
jelly hater put this back in the box
it's more of like a gusher try it but I
I can't eat the whole thing is in the
Box it's more of I'm here to you know
I'm I'm a presenter Dan I'm Talent
there's two there another one yeah and I
didn't know it was
jelly
oh my God I love you guys really
good that's unbelievable so you know
when sometimes you eat chocolate you're
like that wasn't worth it and I'm going
to feel bad about myself that is so
worth it nice I'm glad so that's that's
Anon that
is keep the chocolate coming Jeff that's
all that's good I'm going to do that for
some Christmas gifts oh yeah thank you
thank you such a that's an amazing gift
I'm just saying Jeff if the chocolate
Supply if the that ever turns off then I
might be warming up some
compar I'm just saying that just fixed
all the is he would say Trauma from
watching this man right fix it try one
of these do to eat a snowman yeah
there's a snowman and a penguin which
one do you want I feel like I don't
deserve eating this it's like a work of
art it does feel like that doesn't it I
do don't worry I still eat it I bet it'
be good if you put it in the fridge for
a minute
too I'm going to eat a Snowman and then
I'm going to go man go
man sorry I love you guys all right it's
okay A here don't you feel like we
skipped Thanksgiving this year I feel
like we went straight to Christmas this
year wait it's next week oh my God it's
eggnog I oh I know but I just mean like
decorations I went to the grocery store
it was just straight to Christmas I have
no idea it's been y I don't feel like
that I don't follow that not really we
don't decorate I all the whole oh really
I just feel like like oh good that's
eggnog I never had eggnog what does it
taste like oh that's eggnog what did I
say the Snowman is eggnog oh yeah it's
eggnog it's like a cinnamon malt kind of
okay no it's good yeah egg nong's
delicious it's gross when you think
about it but it's really good yeah don't
ask you have it tastes like holiday yeah
it's like cinnamony like sugar cookie
kind of this one too this one is like um
oh this is so good it's so good it
tastes like Christmas tree like smells
try that one o oh it's like mint maybe
probably mint choc jerky yeah minty
evergreeny oh my God and it stays in
your mouth for a while after you eat it
I love ant like you're still tasting it
for a while put your balls in my mouth
Dan why would you say that sorry why
would you ruin I'm sorry I know that was
inappropriate I just love how sorry I
was
triggered forgiven forgiven say no more
I I love the Anson story I love how it
all came together I just love the craft
the thought look how that's why I'm such
a fan perfect it's done yeah so that's
Chef Sandy they have Chef Sandy in the
kitchen and uh I personally call her
Captain Sandy yeah like I see the OCD
like I this person's life is horrible
when they're not making chocolate I love
it I love it when some's OCD pays off
wow thank you Jeff my beautiful my
brother so fun Mark can I be a brother
and Sons oh wait oh my goodness I have I
guess I'm not a son can we be Bros can
we and
Bros which one is that I haven't even
tried wait I didn't try this one that's
my favorite one right there really okay
I got to try do we try them all after
this I'm not going to eat food after
this I love you guys more than me you
want one thank you for having me I had
one of those y I love you and I really
love your fans they're the nicest people
what are you going to do right now
they're literally the nice people I'm
going to do another podcast in studio
City it's the last one I'm doing of
isn't that where Jay shetty's podcast is
is it in Studio City weird coincidence
this one I've been looking forward to
for so long coming and seeing you guys
but I'm about to do what I'm don't feel
that well you don't feel like doing
comedians podcast like stand up it's
like doing it's like jury duty you're
just like I pushed this it's not Bobby
Le I did Tiger Bell I did Santino this
is a skateboarder named Jason Ellis oh I
don't know I love you Jason but Jason
Ellis Jason Ellis yes okay yes he's a
sweetheart no comment okay I don't know
who he is he's very sweet he's like a
big skateboarder whatever kind of thing
I'm impressed that you can go and sit
through another one now being so you
know late in the pregnancy we'll see
yeah I don't know maybe something's
wrong everyone's like you have so much
energy I'm like maybe I don't know
what's going on good I love you so much
and I'm going to come I'm going to come
visit your house and you'll teach me to
parent yes any questions I'm dead
serious seriously text me any questions
I love you so much and good luck with
it's
ask questions yeah no I'm terrified if I
don't die in child birth I'll be asking
a lot of questions once you get the hang
of it it's like like the second baby
you're like oh this is easy the third
one is like I also I was love I love
doing your podcast I hope I wasn't
boring but it I love that it's not like
so [__] boring no I
just I just mean it's like sometimes
going on podcast now and it's trying to
be really funny and try I think it's
audience just wants to chill with us
right want to hear I agree I love
listening to your podcast cuz it's just
like a super fun heang
and you guys are all the best thank you
they are also there's so many hair
products in the bathroom that's what
want all the fans to know this that's
got to be
AB is that
you I love you bye bye bye thank you so
much
bye oh my god oh that was a treasure
thank youas I
love yeah can't wait to eat a burger
after that I I'm going to be destroyed
today boy this bad my calories are shot
did you try the chocolate so much
chocolate good yeah it was nice very
nice
nice you try all of them uh some tried
two pieces did you try the the Dome
ones those are the best ones the he only
had the the the like the what's it
called jelly jelly yeah oh you got to
you got to try one of the Dome ones not
the jelly
[__] Dad bring it dome for
Hawk bring a dome for Hawk you're
supposed to understand that bring one of
the chocolate
does you know the ones that are like
domes a dome for Hawk for Hawk yeah that
D need a chocolate Dome here thank you I
love those guys so the chocolates left
and so did the crew I don't see anybody
here except love just love and Hawk my
boy
oh yeah did and Zachary and good old
Zach oh and Ian okay andan all right I
could never leave I'm here we'll be here
with the Cockroaches
bro anyway I love Anson's oh here's the
Dome let's get a shot please show the
[Music]
camera yes oh he knows he knows yep go
ahead do half bite not a whole bite what
a
bro
good
technique what's inside what flavor did
you get not jelly hopefully oh looks
like
chocolate chocolate you got the
chocolate one yep the chocolate let me
hit that chocolate
chocolate double
chocolate some crispiness
M nice is this considered f is it's a
sweet that is like coffee yeah not a
good it like you guys enjoyed it no it
wasn't that
good it's good hog keeps getting the the
the weird ones all bring another Dome
please no I mean it's grown up for Chate
bring another dome for maybe maybe a
colorful one bring a dome with
color I had I have two ones with um like
this oh you did but there was sort of
the jelly yeah there was the no no no we
don't do jellies
here what color
Ethan um
um maybe one of the blue each apparently
not any any one of those is fine try one
of the the yeah that one this one these
are probably good call it green let me
see which one you chose yeah okay okay
yeah you'll be good with
that oh my Hawk is engaging the
Dome he is taking a bite hopefully it's
this this is the s'mores one they're
really good try this one o no that's
lemon oh lemon okay yeah that's lemon
that's good one we like the lemon one
here comes the s'mores which one bus
sores what's what's s'mores it's just
graham cracker chocolate and
marshmallow uh he's engaged the s'mores
flavor Dome he's in chewing and thought
that one's busting
yeah it's
okay everybody with the uh he's piy with
the stunning endorsement
of I was really enjoying watching this
[__] guy though me too he's such a
Looney Tune I can't believe what I'm
watching yes what wait till you read the
tweets
[Laughter]
dude oh when his friends hold him
accountable I was working with Brad
warlock to uncover the real issues this
entire time and I said a lot of things
in order to not draw suspicion that
person's name is bread is that a hold on
is that a name
bread like broad no I think that's bread
Haring their name is not bread warlock
wait I'm pretty sure I like bread for a
name bread bread get the bread bread get
that bread
bread I'll let you hear the Things She
Said to not draw
suspicion so um I think it's interesting
that uh bread warlock is it's like
getting into who's bread
warlock everyone's DMS because he got
into mines basically bread come bread
[__] what is that like when it's just not
baked all the way through it's a little
gooey brick I don't know what the [__]
these DMS are but anyway he apologizes
again okay or
anyone
or I don't want anyone to attack a car
or bread warlock or
Lola or anyone please leave bread
warlock
alone I'm just
done you don't want me to go on oh my
god dude you're so
dramatic how you been I've been great
and he came back after his one month
later he comes back oh oh hey happy New
Year how you been I've been great in
major part because I haven't been here
originally planned on coming back and
tell you all the things I did well there
was a way but there really is no point
because either that doesn't matter to
you or you won't be satisfied by
anything that I have to say and I've
continued doing work elsewhere just not
on Tik Tok because frankly Tik Tok what
else is there to say than just sorry
[__] that I don't care how mean that
little girl was to you dude you know
what I mean she was so mean you guys
don't understand she told me to [__] off
on the Internet is toxic as [__] so I
stepped away and exactly what I thought
would happen did you know a bunch of
people had already sharpened their
pitchforks and lit their torches with me
not here they were like what are we
going to do with these apparently the
answer was turn on each other and the
reports I've gotten have just been
disappointing and gross a bunch of
people showed exactly who and what they
are and I mean that in good and bad ways
so very happy to know some people and
there's some other people that well
there's nothing quite so New Year's
resolution is cutting dead weight now I
already had some plans for shifts in
content coming into the new year
recently events have just solidified
that but I will say this I'm not for
everybody some people won't like the
things that I say or how I say them or
the way that I look and that's okay well
I've been yeah I mean the pro the
problem was that you told people to go
harass a 10-year-old and a 12-year-old
that's the problem anyway whatever
whatever blah blah blah so then yourself
this was crazy right but
then on the way to work I was reading
the goddamn tweets who put this together
that was Dan those tweets are
mindblowing aren't they yeah I mean
they're they're all really old like
really really old9 or so but how old is
he uh I wasn't able to determine that I
mean he looks like he's probably in his
40s cuz these most of these tweets are
from granted it's worth mentioning of
course this one's from 2010 so I mean 13
years yeah they're all super old but
they're still like pretty eyebrow how
old is tizzy cuz this is important uh he
might be approaching 50 it's not solid
but these websites like you know uh
celebrity birthdays and stuff say 45
yeah I'm seeing 45 as well so I'm seeing
47 so he was my age when when he wrote
These tweets
approximately right yeah it would have
been in 12 years ago or so yeah so um
bear that in mind here we go Mr
tizzy now hold I was also confused
before I put this on him the AR T does
that mean he just retweeted it or did he
write
it cuz I know old tweets show up
weird yeah that's probably a retweet
right that's the old school retweet well
anyway here's what it is PWS actually
desire premature ejaculation wow smiley
face here we
go it's the best way to reach under 18
males and females hard to promote
detention maybe I should run banners on
you porn
[Applause]
well if your hair is long enough use a
bunch of it to make a ped stash and say
hey kids want some candy get in my van I
mean okay there's a lot of uh hold on
let me keep going here beat my ex-wife
and I'm also a
pedophile well bilie hold on now's not
the time I never did I heard you you
just said it what's the deal with this
album like it's not it's like bugging
out you see
this yeah it's not showing me the other
tweets you see this
Dan weird I don't know why it's bugging
out I did I'm
refreshing I guess let's get a new
folder going for tizzy let's see what
he's up to these
days
um let's see I'm looking for a good one
do unto others okay this is a good
lesson okay let's talk about this really
quickly um so the Grammy nominations
come out among them a gospel singer
named Bobby stormes this is right on we
just talked about
her nomination that's got to be amazing
uh congratulations to her that's
fantastic she got this news though I
believe as she was getting on a flight
and how she decided to celebrate was to
impromptu perform for the other people
on the flight now I want all you guys to
go here's her home here's her address I
want you all to go to her house and tell
her just that it wasn't cool what she
did go to her address go to her front
door go to her
DMS does she have a child go with
especially good to go get them get it
them if you
can and by that from what I can tell I
mean just start singing at them and at
least the staff on the flight took issue
they're enjoying it so while we're
sitting here can I please I'm not
enjoying it so I'm asking you can you be
quiet that's a yes or no uh answer
please am I going to go to jail if I
don't can you please answer my question
are you willing and able to be quiet
right now I'm doing what the Lord is
telling me to do I'm ask you a question
yes or no I'm your flight leader I need
you to follow my instructions okay my
instructions for you to answer my
question are you able to be quiet what
do you guys
think I'm asking you ma'am I'm asking
you guys no okay let's pause there for a
moment um in all varess I added the
Crickets but I did so to sort of
illustrate a p that no one was jumping
in going like let her sing his his
coverage is kind of weird though it's
like humorless seems like he's actually
angry and this is the issue uh anyone
just singing remove religion from the
equation anyone just like singing to a
Plane full of people or
whatever not okay however big of a
deal it's a little annoying but he is
annoying he's like listen singing not
okay so this is like mad social justice
we [__] like I haven't seen this kind of
stuff since like damn 2015 [__] dude
right getting zarna energy from our boy
here humongous this recently around
religion uh singing at people or
preaching to people on planes on trains
on buses or boats I didn't even know she
was doing religious stuff she was just
singing you know stop doing
this just
you're this is not okay what that's
weird that he's making it about
religion he why is he actually upset
about this
though you know that's oh and so just to
punctuate I want to say why is he so
serious about this that doesn't make you
the hero of the story it's interesting
and but I am the hero of this story
telling her it's not okay I want to let
this last little part play out because I
want to illustrate something she said in
that first clip that she felt the Lord
was calling her to do this uhoh and then
this happened big mistake if you're not
able to be to follow my instruction so
okay let's talk about this really
quickly um so the Grammy nominations
come out among them a gospel singer
named Bobby storm received of it all the
next all right thank
[Music]
you I'll sing it on a low for you all in
the bank hold up wait a minute I thought
the Lord told you to sing why are you
not singing if you're going to be
removed from the flight wouldn't that be
like the point like what are you doing
Checkmate atheist [__] Checkmate
Christians where you where's your God
now it's just a cringe of video nothing
more than that serious about this oh my
gosh dude and then we need Justice this
is 26,000 likes so people were down with
this take oh wow God and instructs you
and you're going to be persecuted for
singing isn't that like a thing she said
all that look I'm glad uh she didn't
continue I'm glad she wasn't removed
from the flight no need for all that
there's no need for there to be that
conversation in the first place let's
just try and respect everyone just have
respect that's what it comes down to
it's not respectful to be like hey
everyone listen to this in same way this
guy is not a real person right now holy
[__] you gave him a life I know didn't
do that I did it on accident but uh I
said you know what I'm going to keep it
I'm going to keep it um oh I found a
video of him doing his uh lip
syncing holy
[__] oh my God look at
Ela
oh wow oh this is still on his
page I reposted one of my favorite posts
from back in the day oh this is his
favorite one
okay okay
sure all
right
awesome super cool dude
dizzy getting me dizzy
tizzy here's one of his who is she
videos let's
see what else there what else you oh
just you wait she's a she said the NW
which is obviously horrible St Pete
Florida the person this video actually
is somehow affiliated with a gay bar
where this in part happened um they said
that this woman ran into the bar and
announced loudly my phone was just
stolen by five lesbian
nword and then she proceeded to start
yelling the fs slur at people sounds
like she's
having and then the video I'm on the
phone with the
police you are Jes you are you know
what this isn't my world I don't even
watch that [__] good luck out there dud
though tizzy we love you and we're all
rooting for you we're all rooting for
him
um
so that's
tizzy all
right quite a saga I wish I had the
tweets do we have the tweets yeah I put
some more in there the one I was
confused what you were asking about the
ones I put in there were all the pedo
ones so those were the ones that were
relevant the rest are just like him
talking about wanting burn homeless
people and stuff okay right right right
this is what I watched we got a
technical issue can you all fix that or
is that like a technical issue it's a
technical issue okay hold on we got just
a little technical issue here we have
some technical issue it sounds what do
we do about it what are we going to
[Music]
do you do it you did it already Okay
yeah I said don't I had a note not to
open that because of well just don't
show it I'll read it he said he says
really not sure why tentacle RW would
make me think of I don't know who these
people are Daniel Dennis and Tom van B
and then #
BDM
um he took a photo of a woman on the
train he says having trouble naming this
one it's between meth hooker from
Breaking Bad gets dressed up for court
or taals from the [__] keeper wearing a
Farah faucet
wig great is it just but so Charming
this is this this is the guy who's
like hey everybody be nice or I'll ruin
your
life the who are you
man um see I'm I'm trying to be nice
homeless are not useless without them
who would my friends and I hunt for
sport oh I know
hookers thank you I was just like holy
[__] dude what the hell I know [__] was
like crazy back then like people were
but even for that this is pretty wild
one day I'll open a stress relief
business that allows you to beat or
torch a homeless person
what okay cool
dude life is only as small as your
imagination said the homeless fellow
before smearing fees on his face and
drinking yarn
okay that one's not that bad I guess not
wishing violence on him what the [__] is
his problem with homeless people yeah I
don't know a lot of problems with that
and a lot of like award stuff it just
it's a weird weird vibe oh yeah homeless
people if God didn't want you to burn
them he wouldn't have made them so
flammable Jesus Christ what he's like
homicidal I know crazy I couldn't
believe what I was reading
him this is the guy who's like
constantly um High roading everybody on
Tik Tok
oh relax I don't actually are word
homeless men the only piss I want to
smell on you is my own or the
goats what even it's including Beast
theal now e wait holy [__] right I mean
this is good
[__] um homeless guy out front asks for
a dollar so I can buy some Girl Scout
cookies I almost slapped out his last
two teeth
gross um and I think we read these ones
these are the yeah we've ordered these
ones already so that's
tizzy and we love them and we wish them
and we're all rooting for
them thank
you
wow need to go to the bathroom again go
ahead so other than b the big
Tiz we got a boogie update
and we got Roman Atwood update both of
them I'm looking forward to actually MH
really fun updates from both of
them
um this is going to be really hard to do
I got a lettuce
wrap I got a double Patty lettuce wrap
you guys look at this [__] me too dude I
got a lettuce wrap did you get Triple
though I got a triple lettuce wrap with
bacon oh my God
M it's kind of good you're about to go
into ketosis Bro [__] yeah dude I feel
the heating surging
yeah I am sewing kosis right
[Music]
now You' be surprised how much how
big how many calories is in the the
bread the bread is like half the
battle you
know so if you're just going to slam a
bunch of lettuce and beef I think that's
not that
bad
right
[Music]
both can you put me in Subway or
something fidus can you take can you
take the
lead
go ahead Fus you can host for a little
for a
minute I I I know but to answer uh the
thing I don't I don't
like how catching up for I'm I don't
catch up with anybody like when I was
like when I'm going back to Cyprus or
when she's coming here going to catch up
and talk and like see how each other is
doing not messages or video call like in
real life oh no we didn't meet through
video call okay I can reach out and talk
for one time and like catch up but it's
kind of not how I want to do it so I
don't know it's it's it's good but it
felt kind of wrong I to NE Netherland
where how [__] up I am I and I I
wanted to film The Last I want think
though when I was with you I was
thinking oh yeah in the future I will be
less Fair after we broke up and like
people like still label in yours I don't
know uh I don't know I'm I'm in love
with what I'm doing and right I don't
think about other stuff I'm not sure if
love exist it was how much time for one
and a half here we were together mhm
anything change right
uh thought was very very like I I one
thing that when I was with you I was
thinking oh yeah in the future I will be
less I mean go on it's me it's he really
is insightful I want I don't
want and it's kind of crazy how far hey
get that out of here Olivia idea you're
not allow to drink that on camera my
idea I'm not sure sure if is true or not
if I'm 100% true right but I don't want
to live with a person I will be mared to
it and when you understand conv I'm not
saying that this is true is I'm true to
say to do this and if it's respectful to
the get that I would be M or whatever to
do all these things but yeah it's
interesting you found they're
crazy and they to talk about
psychological stuff and like help you
like for me like I found YouTubers to be
around like help you to be
with well looking the stars and I was
like wow it's been one and a half year
what did what did change like some
things that change in your
mindset like so first it was you were
the first person to kind of on my my
life I was like it's good to share
moments with people it's good to do all
like I I love the having a person to
talk when you're down when you are he's
so good I mean he just sometimes when
I'm alone I am this this is things that
I me like just laying there and like
where huging like just so many problem
but just like that that care that you
have the person I learned that a lot
that a lot just to have a person that
cares about you and yeah it work like me
not hearing about you me know like
helped so much with the pr and also it's
kind of a romantic Pro like it's I
enjoyed it so much like a lot of nights
I was thinking about you like it's very
beautiful those nights actually is like
and actually I feel there is I became
like a person now that I I I don't like
being
happy really that's sad to say
sorry he doesn't like being happy yeah
that's a dark way to
end I wonder if he would call in boogy
can you can we maybe we should did we
reach out we said we want to reach out
to him I would like to talk to him
I like FAS I want him to feel good being
happy not feel bad I thought you were
saying Boogie we have reached out to
fidas we haven't heard back I was
goingon to say um I don't want to end on
that Downer of a note Zach can you play
something more upbeat can I go wash my
hands before I go get yeah
okay man that was a really good
monologue I I was moved by that he's
really good
podcasting you got a burger and a
lettuce thing
I did and I didn't respons I didn't eat
the whole thing either such a
responsible though I got two patties
though sure but no
bread but I did eat like
710 yeah you know I can't eat after all
the chocolate right now that chocolate
hits and the and the
um I forgot the Boba oh yeah the Boba
too we kind of went we kind of did a lot
today to be honest
all right
so uh I did work at a small gaming store
back in no not this boogie this6 2007 I
am disabled uh recognized by
the states there's that now the downside
of that is I am extremely depressed so
there's some mental health issues that
we bring to the table bro and then
physically I I am morbidly obese I have
no references uh no work history I said
up dude what is this and when you Google
my name you might see rumors that I beat
my ex-wife and I'm also a pedophile
should mention I'm also a stop about two
years Jesus dude was trying to to end on
a high note I'm [__] hell
dude all right I never did all right
let's talk about Boogie we got three
great categories left Let's Do It um
first
we're catching up on Boogie
updates uh we and
uh we talked about it on Monday I think
and then we had keem's voice note to
Boogie did you hear this Ela no so
Boogie went on someone else's podcast
and I guess was
um after the documentary came out what
were they fight yeah he got after the
documentary came out he went on someone
else's podcast and got into some fight
with them and then keemstar's like why
the [__] did you do we they're starting
a podcast together they are yeah and
like why did you do this on their
podcast oh and uh so he's upset that he
gave them too much juice yeah listen I
mean this is legendary Keem was in the
chat too and was telling him ahead of
time like don't don't go on here and
yeah he was in the chat stop I I that
was my understanding yeah and who
released the conversation here this
looks like one goons one of the goons I
don't know thick as thieves those Bunch
okay in your stupid fing head your
[__] ret [__] head I talked to you
before you went on in my other group
chat people were like oh boogies calling
into Rich iing called you we spoke I
said don't give Rich the tea your exact
words to me were way sister uh
keemstar this man likes to act like he's
not a tea Channel like he's is not a
drama Channel [__] you just said the te
you said save the te for me
Boogie thank you I'm just going to go on
there and tell him I'm busy right so you
call him the rich you tell him I'm busy
he starts milking you you start
answering every question because you're
an attention fing freak and then you
have a face off with muta on Rich's
stream the face off between you and muta
should be on your podcast that's mon TI
that you make money you in your stupid
[__] head this is not a mistake this
is not an accident you [__] re you
did this on purpose I talked to you
before you went in I [__] hate you
[__] you all the time and effort God
help you guys out and you don't you
can't do the simplest task I [__] hate
you I hate you I hate
you that's really sad obiously I [__]
up uh I was just going to go there to
promote the show I didn't know muda was
going to come in there and pulled his
[__] I should have left when muda showed
up and said save it for the show uh but
you're right I respect your decision let
me know if you need any of the passwords
or anything like that I'll be glad to
hand them over Jesus and
uh it it's interesting like it's like
the nastiest person meets the most
pathetic person it's an interesting
personality Dynamic I think boie like if
and I'm not one to diagnose him but it
kind of seems like he has something for
like suffering and putting himself in a
position of suffering and so I guess
maybe the relationship with kstar kind
of feeds that yeah unhealthy thing that
he has look at this text exchange he
says keemstar says God I effing hate you
boie said yeah I respect that we had to
blur it out cuz it's
so oh my God and then and then Keem says
do you need attention that much that you
gave away our entire effing second
episode he never did blank your face
blank yourself in the face and do it
right now what are you kid that's crazy
yeah that's what he told us same boogy
or I mean keemstar who has a you know
mhm blank yourself not um not the f word
but um no he says on a live yes un alive
himself that's C with a gun in his face
and do it right now also just by the way
Boogie's responding he clearly already
feels like much lower than Keem so when
he chooses to use that language with he
knows what he's doing like Boogie's
already
down well he's got he's got him on a
podcast called the LOL cow podcast and I
said this last time but it's like you
cannot get mad at Boogie he's being a
lull cow he's doing what you hired him
to do
like um is it should I oh God a bobe
message let's see we got I can't believe
this relationship with him him and K
there's like 50 by the
way sad he might be friends you know
tizzy and Keem might be actually
potentially good friends they should
start Bo block said based on these DMs I
think Keem would make a good cow
replacement nice okay true good insight
there Bobs
fing um so but anyway there is some
major updates coming out um wow keemstar
told him here in Discord I sent this uh
time stamp news is this where what's
their deal with mud they like enemies no
well so mudahar was supposed to
be I don't understand dude they have I
don't know the Dynamics they have mud
and a couple other people that are
apparently they call them the milker
it's it's bizarre I mean it it's just
plain bizarre wait it they call
themselves The Farmers actually I kept
thinking I put that in your head cuz I
thought it was milkers uh but I mean we
can just call them that they are milkers
they're milking it yeah they're milking
the utters of
Boogie I need you to [__] off like
seriously [__] off I need you to get on
your [__] hands and knees have your
girlfriend [__] film you and say I'm
sorry keemstar I'm sorry I'm sorry both
of these men have a really young
girlfriend oh so they do
relate yeah and tizzy uh just to include
him he says a hand a beautiful handsome
boy with chestnut brown hair in a
wonderful Australian
accent why don't I bring that up I'll
I'll leave I don't know I just thinking
they all could get along but I'll move
on from him [__] uh Tommy C Nas jorio
muta [__] Tom everybody that's even
[__] cared about the law called
podcast I'm such a self everyone whoes
about the attention [__] [__] that
I just I want attention I want to be in
conversation so bad that I gave an
entire the the entire storyline of
what's been happening on episode one to
[__] review Tech USA cuz I'm thiry to
talk to someone well the truth is like
listen I've been in game this game a
long time it doesn't really matter
because then you got the story of the
story you and it's that's good too it's
you know but he it's probably better we
wouldn't have been talking about it if
this didn't happen but the way that K is
so upset about it he's the real lull cow
think about it yeah right he's the one
that got baited into looking crazy mhm
if I'm not mistaken I believe Keem even
paid for a camera for uh Boogie to do
this podcast like he's all in on
producing yeah this is his uh that's
awesome what what kind of $50 webcam did
they buy did he buy I'm not sure [__]
loser make that video you piece of [__]
he's like hysterical I'm sorry so he
says get on your hands and knees oh God
he does it does it oh my God Hees this
is the new part this relationship is so
dangerous it's so dangerous what's wrong
with this I never did exactly the
message that we read before of him
telling him just go un alive yourself
right now the influence he has is a
little I mean whether or not he's aiming
I don't know it seems Keem has a lot of
influence yeah over
I for time for ab conspiracy but I think
this is all planned no I to a degree I
feel like because their guys leaked it
right they leaked the conversation
initially I think they always ratting on
each other though I mean but this show
is posted by the guy that supposedly
leaked it this episode right here I
think he knows that he can't you know be
successful any other way so now he's
going full returning to his roots with
dropping the uh the r word in every
sentence and just going full insane at
this point yes in the original convo I
think was genuine keemstar being
genuinely angry yeah I could see that
and Boogie being like I'm sorry I'll
give you the keys on yeah I think he was
just trying to recoup the the milk that
he lost or the juice but I don't know
still pretty uh it's pretty sad what's
going on here Tommy it's a technical
issue okay hold on we got just a little
technical issue here we have some
technical issue it sounds like what we
do about it what are we going to
do that's a lot of F words
yeah there was too many F words I had to
I had to button it
out I guess also spare you all from
having to watch that cuz Jesus Christ
I'll just play it you don't need the
audio it's it's just him on his hands
and you the [__]
[Music]
stupid you can bring it back oh boy
want
sorry want all of us on the same page
all right couple days ago pause it pause
it please uh we had to make an edit of
this dude the lighting is SC that's what
I was like what the [__] what the [__]
Jes he's to get blinded he's at an nft
conference right is the kids bowling oi
you know how they have all the like neon
light going bumper bowling night yeah so
we made a edit
because he uh he kept was he keep why
did we make an edit uh he was dropping
the r word a lot oh we had to edit some
strong restarted yeah F bombs want all
of us on the same page all right couple
days ago Boogie sitting here [__]
getting he he's pissed ay his voice is
cracking like he can't even talk through
the pain on the same page I agree that
the first one I think was real but this
ongoing after it was supposedly already
leaked I think at this point he's just
he's he's committing to it listen he his
voice is shaky he's so upset couple days
ago Boogie sitting here [__] getting
mil want all of us on the same page all
right Z you hear it he's emotional want
all of us on the same page all right
he's crying couple days ago Boogie
sitting here [__] getting milked by
just random people by muta by everybody
and he's giving his response to drama
for free on Twitter just spamming it
everywhere and I say Boogie look all
right no more of that all right you want
to address drama you want to address
what some people are saying some some
controversy that's going on with Boogie
298 you do it on the podcast this is 4
minutes 20 seconds yeah it just keeps
getting better really okay let's keep it
you do it on the podcast where you
actually can monetize that's his
basement that's his bar he built his
dungeon yeah and get [__] paid Boogie
oh oh Boogie goes to me oh that's a
smart idea that's a really smart idea no
it's not no it's not it's [__] Common
Sense there's there's no intelligence to
that whatsoever a fifth grader could
figure that out right but you at [__]
age 54 haven't figured that out and you
get milked by the [__] most random
person ever Boogie's 54
wow
whoa that can't be right no he's 49 okay
oh I remember because there's a 20e
difference right between him and his
girlfriend oh yeah 20 years so Kim is
just uh exaggerating Kim's jealous that
he's got a he's got a Leonardo DiCaprio
new girl on his arm
could just go in and [__] milk you
get you all riled up get you spamming 17
[__] TS uh tweets for free or teats
really that's what they're called in a
[__] cow cuz you get milk you [__]
dumb [__] piece of [__] anyhow after
that life lesson that I gave you right I
find out in another chat that you're
going into Rich's stream review Tech USA
I can't watch this whole thing man
420 that's what it sounds like that's
all I'm hearing yeah yeah it the same
thing he said in the voice
notes
um so here's the meme of Boogie that
keemstar tweeted out and I guess this is
the new uh this is the new this is what
you wanted dude goes I swear this is
what you
wanted this is some weird fetish stuff
it's drifted into uncomfortable
fetish what the what are you you doing
what are you doing here I did I don't
know let see where keem's coming from I
kind of like what his new
Direction you
know 41 old ass loser dumbass [__] sad
pathetic so that's it that's all I have
to say about
buggy pretty good though yeah I never
did I never
did um all right let's move ahead on to
Roman Atwood I was up wait we uh we have
um we have a guest actually sitting in
the lobby oh this [__] no not
that
[__] don't say that yeah yeah
yeah yeah somebody you're actually
excited to see wait this is hold on this
is out of pocket this is too far oh my
God they're T clearly they're talking
about sandwiches there's no that's
that's not to imply any 10-year-old fan
right away that's [__] up I don't I
don't know who I this is not
we don't condone this and uh there's no
evidence or anything like that to say
anything about well obviously other than
Jared who's in jail but these other two
guys are there's not there's not even
allegations so let's not even go there
if this was real it was cuz they were
talking about sandwiches 16 is the age
of consent but it's not real all right
and we're seen enough thank
you yeah uh let's bring him on I know
who you're talking about now who I've
been trying to get him on the show all
week and this poor guy been like on hold
as I talk to Mike Lindell or or mediate
Jimmy Le
yes Drama Oh I know who this is
cardama oh is
cardamon it's so my name's cardamon but
if you're going based on my artist name
it's cardo cardo cardo cool yeah I love
you oh bless you [__] H I love your
music it was so I that song is just
amazing I know you didn't win but oh I
didn't need to win don't worry about
that but you were my in Ethan's heart
yeah and so I was like man I got to talk
to this guy see what's up what's the
deal why why aren't you
famous um because a lot of people love
to ignore me but um first things first I
just wanted to clear something up so I
go by they them pronouns and I identify
as nonbinary okay that's totally fine I
obviously you you guys didn't see my
pronouns in the bio or whatever so I'm
not like offended or anything I just
wanted to like thank you for telling me
I'll yeah thank you yeah that's totally
fine no worries um but yeah uh thank you
so much the response has been
overwhelming already and even just you
like reposting the [__] like
Instagram story I've got like 500
followers from that which was just
lovely awesome everybody's lovely thank
you so much but it's it's like okay so
another question we had is the second
voice is that you or another person oh
every everything's me wow okay
interesting wait let me play this song
again cuz I just love it and
I how long take you to make
this hours really that's it oh my God
what how did you make all them
background music and stuff oh my god
I've been producing for seven years oh
my God amazing so can you tell us a
little bit about the process like how do
you
make yeah sorry if you can turn it down
yeah you can do both um basically uh I
don't do all of the sound design myself
because then it would take very long but
basically um most producers know about
this and surely some of you guys will
have heard of splice basically splice is
a sample um library that you can sign up
to and you get credits and you can use
those kind of samples in your
Productions with um uh free rights in
the same way that you use um I forget
what the one Zach uses but um there's
like a library of songs that you can use
that of royalty free same kind of vibe
but um splice is often commissioned to
other artists to make packs and then you
use those and everything um my whole uh
my whole thing is uh I like the freedom
to create and steal artist derivative
and I do believe that we should be free
to steal and sample from anything so
long as making it um somewhat our own
and somewhat transformative uh like you
know your whole thing with the copyright
issue I I think that is in a really good
place at the moment in music so um with
splice that kind of um facilitates that
whole thing to happen so I take a lot of
sounds and then I [__] around with them
and I see what happens and uh basically
throw [__] out the wall and see what
sticks that is so cool all right let's
let's hear this
[Music]
I head
heart do you like like far as the songs
you've written is this a Bop even for
you cuz this um so or is it just a meme
song um so it started as just a meme
song but then I was
like it's kind of it's great it's like
all I was like oh [__] I kind of went
off on this Hest oh that's so funny how
that happens I feel like every creative
kind of goes through that in a in a in a
way sometimes where it's like I did this
totally UNS seriously and ended up into
something like awesome right yeah I mean
I released an album in August and um I
really didn't expect it but when
everybody listened to it like all my
friends and like the the few people that
I ended up reaching through like my own
sort of campaigning um one of the like
uh what I called the like interlude
tracks um ended up being like a fan fa a
fan favorite and it's literally just a
song about frogs and I was just like I
was like oh my God I spent so much time
making the other stuff like wait I want
to hear that one where do I hear the
frog one oh for [__] sake Ethan oh my
i' I've I've got a single out today play
that one
instead oh I mean sure you have a single
out today okay yes I I literally just
released a single and it's fantastic and
it's with one of my friends flourish and
uh if any if anybody out there what's
wrong with the frog one man you sold me
on that the frog one bangs you can
listen to all of fan favorite I mean I
think I like the
Frog can we do both so if you um do you
want me to send a link to it on
Spotify uh do you have it on Soundcloud
I Oh Yes actually I do on Soundcloud
it's frogs are more precious than
diamonds that's the one let's hear it
this is it wait real quick have you
uploaded this through any type of
distribution service or anything yes
however um it's through Dr kid and um I
do not have the YouTube um uh scanning
thing on ah very this Dro kid is my
[__]
Nemesis I hate that
kid should be um and everybody go to AST
kids Instagram and tell that that he
[__] sucks and that his girlfriend
deserves better all right let me listen
to this Frog
song all right this is going to get
claimed right oh look I hope
not all right I think it'll be
okay do you love
frogs yes good me
too
[Music]
you don't have to stick around for a
whole you can't just like I'm here we're
in the moment we're in the moment I'm in
the Frog
bit frog think that it would really do
me some good having a little [__]
frog just to look after and look at
sometimes and feed it and keep it alive
and the things you generally do when you
have a frog it would probably die though
because I'm simply not in the right
mindset to look after another life let
alone something as precious as a frog I
never even had a dog I really wanted one
but my parents said it would [__] up our
oak wward
flooring that's not cool I'd rather have
frog
anyway
FR di I wish they were up so I could
ride them FRS are way more precious than
diamonds and it's way less problematic
to find them frogs are [__] awesome
they're my favorite amphibian I also
love GTO frogs are cool find milon frogs
are [__] cool times a
million press the diamond I wish they
were big enough so I could ride them BR
way more precious and diamonds and it's
way less
[Music]
problematic love
that all right let me Jam your new
single and then we'll we'll uh W I love
frogs I already love frogs I love them
even
[Applause]
more the um this one's a is a hit man
cardama when you're not there that's
yeah popular track literally is now um I
haven't got the new single on Soundcloud
but I'm going to send you a link to it
on
Dropbox okay send that to Dan and he'll
uh
[Music]
no I'll take all of the above it he hit
Ean hit the button oh God why cuz he's
just yeah suck for saying guy no F he's
trying he's trying I I corrected myself
and it was just a mess but I I buttoned
it out no you're good you're good um
trying to remember if this is the one oh
[__]
okay I don't need I don't need anything
baby my SST
I can write a b about you and if no one
even ever read it baby that's fine baby
I'll tryong for you yeah that's what I'm
going to
[Music]
do Olivia I'm sending this link to you
but only so I can then um find it on my
computer oh okay cool so I don't have to
do anything you mean oh okay
it's so good yeah you your voice is
amazing stunning stunning
stunning
so I'm I'm fully on board I'm here to
make it happen I it's my what can I do
go listen to
card where do you where do you want
people to follow you like on Soundcloud
on Instagram on where's your where's
your best place um Spotify and Instagram
are my two main um things at the moment
so what is the Instagram handle so my
Instagram is card. MP3 so that's c a r d
m o.
MP3 so it should be easy to find apart
from the fact that I just recently got
like I got
um uh I don't know what it was but I
made some like stupid comment on a on a
real and I think my Instagram got like
restricted or something
what did you really yeah basically
basically there was like a video of
somebody making sharmma out of like um
mushrooms and I was like faking being
offended I was like how could you do
this but then my caption was quoting
Britney broi and it was like I'm going
to kill you with a gun oh yeah that'll
do
it'll
it they don't like yeah so I think me
and Ethan have something in common in
that regard we do we do yeah
yeah it's not a good thing but it binds
us and it is what it is exactly and uh
so that was my Instagram and then
Spotify you can find me just at cardo so
c a r d m o I've been told that it's
quite hard to find me because of the way
I stylize it with the delta in my name
because I'm that's the one all right I
got it yeah Lena and ab I don't know
whether you guys have heard of um Mahal
I think would have would know it as
Mahal it sounds familiar I Lena just
went outside to walk Alfredo but she'll
probably know she's more familiar yeah
it's it's a Lebanese dessert oh I know
it we call it malaby what is it yeah
that's the one so this it's like a I
don't how do you describe it it's like
so it's like a custody kind of photo
gelatinous yeah but the basically I'm
half cypria and I remember going to
Cypress and seeing my family and we'd
have Mahal yeah oh and it's like super
like floral and fragrant yeah we've had
it in
y yeah yeah yeah yeah and basically I
made a song about it with my flourish
and this is my new single called Mahal
here it is and I'm going to open the
Mahal Mahal
[Applause]
it tast sweet if you ever leave
[Music]
I think you a from I think you know what
I
want come with me got a craving for
something sweet trying to get you
underneath me baby know what I mean
spice and everything that's nice want to
s for you
[Music]
baby just if you would let me have a
taste I'm so rather nice
baby you taste s
[Music]
ever
my
baby wait where's that music from oo
where where do you get that solo from
you playing that oh no God no
splice okay wow that's powerful tool
credit yeah that's me yeah that was
[Music]
me
nice
baby just if you would let me have a t
theat back it is back oh it's back
[Applause]
[Music]
back this Str
is you played the strings on this part
right yeah yeah
beautiful love
it every night I look to the skies and I
hope an angel will pass me
by and once or twice I get this feeling
inside that
maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
I have no idea how that
splic sick it sounds like a cool way to
how do you get it other
artists so complex it it sounds like the
stuff from splice is already existing
and then you use
it um so
basically um in regards to that song um
a lot of it isn't just splice like the
only thing in that song that is splice
uh well no not the only thing but the
only thing that's like kind of Taken
almost directly from splice is the um
the buzuki sample so
the but the rest of it is pretty much
sound designed by me and flourish who is
my bestie and co-producer so please
follow up flourish as well he's
absolutely fantastic that's its flourish
sound there it is so um very good well
thank you I mean thanks for submitting
the song obviously I loved it and uh I
think that I just thought it was so good
that I thought I want you know more
people to see what you're up to and you
know I think a lot of people will like
foll you and what you're doing
so that's so lovely thank you guys so
much for the opportunity
I yeah it's it's been difficult recently
I can't lie I mean um I've just started
a job at um a con like a call center so
I'm literally living the worst life
possible oh no um any help is
appreciated um and I'm not going to ask
for donations or anything but streaming
is the best thing ever I mean and
sharing and everything and all of that
stuff mhm so please get me out of the
call center we'll be streaming yeah get
them out all right I'm going I'm on my
way to Apple Store to stream it on all
the devices there do it oh my God yes on
one volume
overnight all right uh thank you so much
nice to meet you so nice to meet you
looking forward to seeing what you do
favorite brand ever oh my God my God
stop it thank you so much sorry about
that you had were staying on the line
during that Jimmy leag call that was
pretty interesting right I was I was so
[__] confused I was like he was on
hold the entire time oh my God I mean it
was interesting I was thinking God if
they pull me in now what am i g say I
didn't want to do that to you we thought
I actually genuinely considered it I was
about to add you to the room just cuz we
were adding as many people and was like
can't do this do I didn't want to do
that to cheeky
bastard there it is Cardo thank
you family family
family thanks see you we'll be
following keep it
up good night we'll be streaming
card mhm that's a pop star right there
if I've ever seen one you know what I'm
saying all right so we've got um we did
buggy we've got Roman Atwood and we've
got uh what was the other
one oh that's it
[Music]
that's let's just let's we had today
let's just avoid that combo are you cing
I don't know
three I think last was five is that six
really this might be the record it's
been a button number five five there you
go
set set we don't need to talk all right
let's talk about Romey My Boy
Romeo and then we can get the fridge out
of here I think the Angels threw her
down and made sure she was not coming
back oh my
God that can't be what happened
man all right so we're we're doing a
deep dive on our boy Roman and
um we've been looking deep into the Pod
the podcast specifically is uh is a real
breeding ground it doesn't add up in my
head sure doesn't honestly it really
doesn't add up the story no he's right
he's right he's right and I do think
that that is number one s
oh definitely some funny business and
then the whole thing about like I had a
dream that I'd marry someone else that's
straight up dat line NBC feel like I've
watched that episode I have seen that
episode and they're Mormons which is an
extra little interesting angle you know
anyway here's Roma talking about trans
folks I'm sure he's going to have an
enlightened take about that badly be
able to change their gender uh before
they're even allowed to get a tattoo why
why are they why are you able to make
that kind of decision before you can
even drink alcohol yeah you shouldn't be
able to make it's not even true I don't
I don't my first question is just Why do
you care go drink alcohol go do whatever
you want they that's not really true
though people are not like getting sex
change oper I'm assuming that's what he
means when he says changing gender
because I
mean then why is it a big deal at all if
someone does like hormone blockers or
something not adding up to me life a lot
of stuff ain't adding up to you Roman
a it's all ain't adding up to me man
flowing decision shouldn't be made until
your brain doesn't even develop until
you're 25 years
old okay all right I mean it's just a
little good old ignorance not a big deal
yeah kind of ironic though I mean the
same argument can be made about putting
kids on video before they can consent to
it which he
does what about you well I don't know
what's what's wrong with pretending your
child got exploded
I I just don't see well here what's we
kind of determined that that one was
fake though right like like the wife was
in on it or whatever I mean it's still
insane thing to do I thought you were
asking if the kid exploded I'm like no
he's good oh yeah no that kid is
definitely he blew up so here's Romeo uh
but I mean when you're talking about
kids I think this is more more uh his uh
Rhythm Guys today we're going to see how
parents react when we flash their kids
awesome
nice that's a awesome I wonder how
they'll react I'm glad we have this
video to get to the bottom of this that
was funny man I was so funny with a
positive
[Music]
message what the hell excuse me what
come on you think i' actually do that so
sorry oh why would she expect anything
else is this one of his old vide don't
touch her dude give me a hug yeah this
is one of his old videos never seen that
one he's a dude he is a m God she's a
give me five he's a devout Mormon which
just again it's like it's all not adding
up 45 million views on the
original that's a
spicy and I believe he became a Mormon
later in life he converted yeah
converted Mormon I need to know the
timeline when w and after
what H he talked about that when did the
mom thing happened that happened
recently I think I think they converted
after his mom died like what I was
thinking
yeah all right let's see more of him uh
um essaying
children kind of I mean kind of it is
kind of still isn't it not essay but
it's not
appropriate harassment it's definitely
it's still sexual even though the way
that he's unring is is kind of
traumatizing you know it's weird and he
goes it's like who I think it's also
traumatizing for the parent yeah
stranger danger big
time I'm going I'm
[Music]
going peekaboo I see you you ever seen
anything like this have you ever
seen it's a joke dude look look look
don't do drugs drugs oh man get that
also the come on some of those kids are
so young they can't even read so they
don't even know what the joke is they
don't even understand what you're doing
no this is horrible this is just the
worst was that funny I guess it was
funny though [__] what the [__] do I
know 45 million views I don't have any
videos with wrong L I don't know what
the [__] funny apparently not
[Music]
really you ever seen this before
he's like you really thought I was
showing my dick to your daughter you
ever seen one of these
before you really think I would do that
it doesn't even work as like a double
meaning for the shirt right know yeah
I've seen a shirt before
dude of course we thought you were
flashing come here watch
out don't do drugs don't do
drugs
awesome I mean uh probably some or all
of these are fake I don't know but but
uh mhm I hope they're fake I honestly
don't know I don't know honestly it
doesn't really make sense cuz you're
still doing it in front of a kid it's
weird yeah I mean when you're when
you're planning this with a child uh
it's yeah still
weird peekabo
peekaboo oh my God what are you doing
look that seemed fake yeah she's
miked come on we're shooting video over
here I don't know if she's fake what you
think that's awesome I thought you were
flashing her naked that one's fake
though that one's definitely fake are
you
okay yes you are give me [__] so he he
understands that it is it is scary for
them he goes are you okay I know I'm so
sorry the other one girl he's like were
you scared and she's like no and he's
like oh you weren't
scared you're so brave anyway Roman was
a [__] Menace
up next we've
got more
[Music]
transphobia here we go it's crazy how
many people I hear talking about this
stuff and those kind of conversation is
like should kids do that blah blah blah
I don't I so I think it's like they
genuinely just don't understand I think
it's just pure ignorance like they just
heard people like Tucker Carlson talking
about it and they're just repeating what
they heard you know
because it's really not like that a man
trying to be a female to promote beer
right an American all am that's really
not that's correct he he thinks Dylan
Mulaney was trans to sell beer right
that's pretty interesting Theory wait is
that no that's what he said if you're
going to use a he he literally I
mean a man mm trying to be a now to
promote beer that's it it's all the
trans movement is a conspiracy to sell
beer and it worked really good you
remember Kid Rock he's like I'm going to
stck up and all these bought a lot of
Grandpa's feeling
frisky right an American all American if
you're going to use a female why not use
a female that was born a female that's
bro uh because they do that 100% of the
time I'm saying there's there's tons of
those already bro watch those you know
it's like I'm sure that there's like all
of them are that capable of birthing
children and raising them um how about
dealing with a period every single month
why not just give a woman that position
right but like would Thrive if they did
that so what's the agenda watch I never
seen he cares about
us yeah you know's I've never seen a a
woman in a beer commercial before he's
right that's so true they would Thrive
you guys would thrive in a beer
commercial how gracious of you Roman
thank you it's okay he just invented
models you guys have periods too by the
way which is which is cool I don't know
what his point was there why I'm
confused by that why is Woman of the
Year not a not a been a woman biological
forever like if I was a woman woman if I
was a woman I would be pissed it's just
but we're not it's just one year I
haven't met a woman that is pissed about
it so I see yeah a beautiful woman of
the year that's actually so psychic you
be like I cannot believe a transwoman
woman woman of the year I'm angry for
women I a great woman could have won
that award and it was robbed like all
the trans people in sports they robbed
them that should have gone to like
anyone really takes those awards that
seriously anyway he does okay he's super
pissed about it I would be so pissed
like I've seen people compar very bold
words coming from rman Atwood who check
notes was 25 when he met his wife at age
17 that I were coming up next
oning like um some of the the the men
women
transgender men women I'm getting it all
backwards to like doing blackface right
is it like literally making fun of women
what and they're getting their parts and
they're getting their roles and they're
get they're beating them in you are
getting it all backwards it's a whole
thing that um I saw I think it maybe it
was Candace ens I don't know one of
those people they are talking
specifically about Dyan mulany because
her style is very like girly so they're
like why would you want to transition
into a woman and then be like this
stereotypical girl but that's just her
style I don't understand what's the big
deal like there's a million other women
are all different styles there's all
kinds of different women no one wants to
believe it though I don't know why some
that are talking point for them really
took off it's it's uh I've seen it a lot
this is actually such a psycho analogy
to be like trans women is like white
people doing blackface mhm dude like he
did right he's and exactly it's it's a
it's a it's a self-report right this is
from today by the way still yeah the
Dyan isation and this is this today this
is Riley gains the swimmer that um
really really bad at
swimming Place likeit women oh [__]
sorry so she's still bitching about that
on she's still she's made a whole career
out of she couldn't she couldn't make a
career at swimming so back up got fifth
place in a swim meet uh like 3 years ago
it's awesome uh lost
uh there was a trans swimmer who I think
got fourth then also didn't place also
didn't
place so Riley here was robbed of her
fourth place placing in a college swim
meet so very it's very important well
done well done very important stuff so
anyway that's uh let's see here um this
is my favorite as that tweet said Roman
started dating his W or I don't even
think they're married I think they're
she's his girlfriend which is super
weird since they're they're Mormon they
are probably Mar they always refer to
each other as like boyfriend and
girlfriend still to this day yeah I
don't think they's not like yeah they're
married and he was married previously as
well before her
okay okay okay okay anyway so he was 25
and she was 17 when they met here's a
nice little story about
um another podcast hit she's saying
she's mad at would or Rome Roman because
he didn't go to prom with her he was
such a buzz kill Grandpa's feeling a
little frisky
today go to prom with me so I never went
my senior year yeah wow he was too old
that's yo so no way you guys I went
junior year but so you never went to
your senior prom no I'm not going to lie
I was was one of those guys that was
like prom so dumb bro you are 25 do you
know how weird it would be if you went
to that
I guess you made the right call look
like a teacher you you'd look more like
a teacher than than the people the kids
there I went to it the year after I
graduated high school I my girlfriend
was a year younger than me so it was her
senior prom and I felt weird and I was
like I think I was still 18 at the time
I haven't even turned 19 yet and it was
already like this is [__] bizar true
even at that age like one year
difference like so much yeah exactly
he's 25 and she's 17 dude he might as
well be their
parent um I sent you guys the um the the
Instagram that I've SE with me so I
never went go ahead if I sent you guys
on WhatsApp if you want to check if it's
worth watching I can't really remember
but if it was a long time ago that I saw
it about Dyan so um and I love how he
plays it off like I you know I'm just
kind of the one of those guys that's
against prom Roman wouldn't go to prom
with me so I never went my senior year
yeah wow oh so she didn't go that's yo
so
no way so you guys I went junior year
but so you never went to your senior
prom no I'm not goingon to lie I was I
was one of those guys that was like
prom's so dumb like why would you do
that but I wasn't I wasn't very uh maybe
fun on that level probably made her miss
prom with her boring old man she's
dating God she be embarrass do you do
you regret things like that like Roman
wouldn't go to prom with me so I never
went my this is nuts I mean they're
married she's an adult but mhm they have
kids and [__] but still that's pretty
[__] dicey some would say the diciest
right Z some would say that yes many
I've
said um so there's him oh yeah and side
note Logan Paul this is a great clip he
called me scum of the internet and
compared me to keemstar recently when he
was talking oh yeah I remember so Roman
Atwood got doxed or something
um this was a crazy take by Logan yeah
he had like a stalker supposedly like
that was uh interfering that's from two
years ago yeah so Roman Atwood had a
stalker and he was going through some
[__] I don't remember what but Logan
Paul's analysis was this it's very
interesting the guy access to his power
grid that terrifies me cuz he has
children children that's like what where
are the cameras facing do you get what
I'm saying like yeah I hear creepy
stories about that stuff all the time
that's get like why couldn't they get
like a a a scum of the internet
[__] like keemstar H3 honestly
Daniel Keem he's one of the biggest most
well-respected boxing news
sources he's the one that bro was the
breaking news about the lack of interest
in your in your Floyd Mayweather fight
he he DET saved him dude Mike you should
have let him stewing in that [__] let
him cook last week and said that there's
a mass massive beef Brewing between you
and Jake he wanted me so this was after
the suicide forest but before the crypto
Zoo right kind of sat right in between
those two things when he was calling you
a scumbag definitely keemstar and uh e
oh there it
is I can't you're not there you're not
there you're not there I can't see
you're not there okay okay guys that's
it right you calling it you calling it
you you miss is the weekend you missed
the link oh teacher we we what about the
homework what about
homework what
maybe you s uh you skipped one of the
videos which video stting number four
listen I'm trying to give love I'm
trying to give love his highlight I know
what you're doing I know what you're
doing right now than
[Music]
brother by baby
he speed in the gritty a g is shaking
fornite let's go a g is shaking
fornite what did I
miss number four in the
document oh I didn't
know that's another CL there one one
more I will say never ever was I
searching for a young girlfriend I never
ever thought of you as 17 or I've got a
17-year-old girlfriend never it was I'm
truly like my heart and everything is so
drawn to you there was no that's uh me
when I'm Woody Allen talking to my
stepdaughter dude that's a fog horn
moment
[Music]
other there was nothing I could do about
it yeah I thought you were very
attractive very cute well I was yeah for
sure dude I was a mass long hair
band yeah but like that's what I'm
that's what I'm into no that's what I
was into really all right we love we
love love all right we love love and uh
Love Is Love rules Love Is Love rules in
the work of the great J Ste yeah love
rules he's so wise love
reals love rails all right hell yeah
nice angle all right let's play a song
that's a great angle for you thank you
to hold on thank you to our
members thank you guys for your support
it makes a huge difference thank you
thank you thank
you don't forget complex con this
weekend complex con come stay hi
Saturday Sunday today we'll be having
MTG booster packs get your
pack don't because if there's leftovers
then I might have enough to build a
deck how many packs you need to build a
deck a deck is 60 cards so and a pack
has 15 or 20 I
forget I don't remember I'm a I'm a fake
nerd bony poser poser so anyway uh
thanks guys for watching in have a great
weekend uh Hawk is leaving on
sun the hawk is returning to the nest oh
no the hawk is uh that's right he's
returning home to roof and uh yeah we
wish him safe travels across the
ocean any parting words for the people
at
home stay safe let's be careful out
there hell yeah
that's good advice that's good advice
that is that is I like that those are
well in a way he's saying watch your
back that's right it's kind of a threat
watching you well it's a hawk Hawks have
tremendous Vision uh that's an eagle
whoa uh Ian you were just playing a
video of an eagle that was kind a h I'll
say we've been enjoying all the memes by
the way thank you guys everyone for
being so kind to my dad it's very
nice all right play off for Christ's
sake
oh yeah
nice last night we
the wased up by baby
he
evened in the gritty Grim shaking
Fort a grim is shaking
fortnite